learn how to use the pi qt5 framework to
create a modern music player Pi qt5
makes it easy to create guey
applications with python in this course
Thomas Burns will teach you how to
create a music player that features a
beautiful and modern user interface
playlist and favorite songs
functionality custom context menus for
different pages and a background
slideshow for every song so let's start
learning hello everyone my name is
Thomas and in this video you and I are
going to build the most advanced and
modern python music player you can
currently find on YouTube Let us look at
what you're going to build because it
looks like I'm bragging about it so
much this is what we are going to build
you can see that is the interface is
fully customized and it doesn't have the
default title bar it's a custom title
bar this is where the song that is
currently playing will have the name
displayed and then the path to that
particular song you can add song to to
your favorit or a particular playlist
that you have created this is the volume
control which I will like to bring down
to about 20 now and these are playback
controls the you can see the beautiful
hover effects that each of them gives on
their H and this one uh is the loop one
song and then this is the random play or
the shuffle this is our music
slider and then this is the default song
list page
that is when we Lo load songs this is
where they will come and then this
button will help us to add songs this
one helps us to delete and then this one
helps us to delete all but if you look
down here you can see that there are
some three boms here what they do is to
navigate between several pages in the
application so if I click on playlist
now you see that the playlist page opens
and then you have some playlist here
that I created you can actually create
your own or remove selected or remove
all I think at this point I we have to
remove all playlist and then we create
some from scratch if I come to favorite
2 I have some songs in favorit that I
can actually click and play so if I
click on this one and then hit
play so the song is playing and then the
slider is also moving accordingly let me
stop it and oh not zero so let's come to
the playlist side and then let's see if
you want to create a new playlist let me
just
say new one and then I can right click
on it and then uh see load selected but
it doesn't have any song so but if I
double click on it sorry this one went
to the second screen if I double click
on the playlist it pops up uh small
window pops up which should show me all
the songs in the playlist you see that
currently there was no song in the
playlist but if I come to song list and
let's load some song
songs let me load this my songs here and
then I can choose to play it it will
work as you have seen and if you also
noticed I when I click to play a new
song the background picture Chang so
this application has background slide
show for every song that you play and
that is a very very cool feature that
you are going to build so if I press on
the next check it see that the
background picture will change to a new
picture I press next next next next and
automatically knows how to go to the
first song when it reaches the end of
the list and that is also another very
cool feature but if I want to add this
particular song to playlist that is
playing this one is that is highlighted
I just click on add to playlist
currently there's only one playlist that
I have new one so I click on it and then
okay it looks like nothing has happened
but let me just pause this song and then
come here the playlist when I double
click I don't know why this one always
comes to the second screen when I double
click you see that that song Raising Me
Higher that I added has been uh is
showing here so we know that that song
is in that particular playlist and if I
also decide to add the song that is
playing to favorite currently it is not
playing let me play it again see that
it's Raising Me Higher that it's playing
it's not part of our favorites if I
click on out to favorites I see it here
in real time so this is what we are
going to build if you are excited about
it just hit the like button and then
share it to your friends who who might
be
[Music]
interested
okay so let us get
coding before we start I want you to
visit this GitHub repository which the
link will be in the description below
you will see that there are two branches
the starter and then the main the main
will have the complete application this
starter has the files that we need to
get started be sure that you're on the
starter branch and then clone the
repository into any editor of your
choice I'll be using py Chon for this
tutorial as you saw so so any editor of
your choice and then let's get
started so when you clone it this is
what you see the file and folder
structure here the ETS folder just
contains folder for the background
images and the images to that have been
used in the app or the say like the
icons themselves also and then you see
here that there is a maini file and then
the music. there's the r and then the
re. QRC so this tutorial is targeted for
beginners also so if you are beginner to
the PT framework is also a right place
for you to be and I will explain
everything uh as you need to know so
let's say so is the directory where my
folder uh my project is sorry and if I
want to open the terminal
here okay so this is a terminal I'll
will be using the windows terminal the
get Bash one if you don't have this
option that says open in terminal
probably you have not installed the
windows terminal you can go ahead and
install it or if you're on Windows you
can just click this address bar and type
CMD that should open command promt for
you in that particular
directory and so that should also do but
I prefer this terminal so that is what
I'll go with the only requirement after
having python installed is to have pt5
and then pt5 tools installed so if you
do pip list whether you are using a
virtual environment or you using your
default python if you do pip list you
should see that
pyqt5 and then pt5 tools are all
installed great if you don't have it
it's quite simple you can just do pip
install and then Pi kt5 please check the
casing is very necessary you leave a
space and then Pi qt5 D
tools
you see that I have it so it says
requirement already satisfied so let's
clear up this
thing
and let me come back here you see the
main. file that is the UR file that
we'll be
using the reason we install the P qt5
tools is that so that we get access to
the QT designer that we can use for the
designing of our UI there are two
options for even for the UI for you to
Cho from and I'll show you and I will
tell you the difference very soon but if
you are looking to learn more on how to
use the QT designer and even PT itself
you can check out my channel uh that is
Tom code based I have a great tutorials
on pyqt5 and other Stacks that you might
be interested in especially if you are
in today's software development
staff okay so the QT designer usually
some time ago I used to type
designer
Des exe or without the exe and I was
able to open it straight from my
terminal but now it doesn't work I don't
really know why what I did some
configuration that I forgotten so I will
show you how to get access to the QT
designer after installing it with the
p5- tools you would want to go to where
your default python where your python is
so if you installed it on your default
python like I did I have it on my
default python I'm not using a
environment then you want to go to where
your python is installed on your
PC so if I should open a new window here
you let me paste this address this is
where my python is usually it will be at
uh local dxc users and then your your
username mine is Tomy and then updata
local programs python for the windows
people uh if you Mar or Lup I think it
should be easier also to locate where
your python was installed if you have
problems with that you can do a quick
Google search and then you get to this
place where I am I only have one version
of python 3.8 so you just click on that
one and then you come to this place
where you see um lib and those one let's
just click on the
lib the one with the capital L there
there are two there okay the one even
has an S but this one is only Li and
then from this place you come to sit
packages when you come to sit packages
come to qt5 applications and then from
here go to QT and then go to the bin
folder here you see a couple of files we
are not even interested in any of them
what we need is the designer. exe this
one you double click
it and then it will open this interface
for you so what you want to do to save
yourself from coming through all these
stress to open the designer is that you
can right click on it on your tax bar
you can't see my tax bar the moment but
if you right click on it you will have
the option to pin it from task bar you
see that mine has already been pinned
the taskar if I W pin it uh then I can
right click on it and pin it to the
taskbar again so so that to be on the
task bar anytime I need it I can close
it uh now and anytime I need it I can
just open it from my txk bar I think I
didn't pin it back so let me open it
from
here okay
pin and then let me make sure that it's
pinned okay so if I close it now I will
not open it from this folder let me
close it and then open open it from my
taxk bar so that I will not go through
so much stress again so after that you
have this opened in your task bar what
we want to do is
to open the UI file and then do the
inspection
so here you go to open because you
actually want to open a file I'll paste
in the address to where the file is that
is where my project is so that is the
address to where this uh folder is that
is what I've opened so let's first
inspect the the
main and then this is it uh in QT
designer if you are new to this um this
shouldn't be so difficult to graas it's
just that the widgets are here what when
we say widgets in pi qt5 or QT is just
the other the things that you see used
to build your app so the buttons the
slider and everything that you see on
this screen is a widget the test and all
and this is where our object inspector
is we can look at all the widget we have
added the names and
uh the classes of each of them and the
property editor is where we edit the
properties of any particular so if I
pick the song list withget is I can
addit the properties of that and then uh
we have the resource browser that
contains the if we have any resource
file yes we do have one for this project
and that is what is also the
KC this one re. QRC and I really
encourage you if you are pqt use pqt
just I encourage you to use the resource
file instead of just the raw path to the
images or the icons that you use because
it comes with so many advantages one of
it is that if you are even on a
different operating system it to be
easier to run the application without
any errors and then if you are also
packaging it you don't actually even
need to add the images to it you can do
away with the images and then once you
convert it to the uh resource file to a
python file you have to if you can even
delete all the images if you want to and
then you app will still be running okay
so the resource file was just if you
don't know how to create it you can just
click on this pencil and then it will
bring up the resource file it
automatically picked it from the
directory where it is just I just added
the images that are in this images
folder here uh let me cancel this
operation so I just added them so that
we can reference them in our application
there is also some actions that I wrote
Because we will along the line if you
saw the demo I right clicked on uh
something in the playlist and the popup
came so the context menu as it is called
we using actions to create them so these
are the actions that are in the
application the action to play pause and
all the other default stuff that music
players do there is also the signal and
Slot editor where I've created a few
signals so if you see this one it says
the volume down this is the volume down
I have made it such that if it is
moved then I want to change the volume
label to the particular number that the
uh so if this is moved this is a label
on top you can see I click it you see
that the bounding box has come and then
it's different from the dial itself I
just put it on top of it so what I'm
saying here is that if the slider is
moved this handle is moved it should get
the value that has it has been moved to
I set the minimum to zero and then the
maximum to 100 as you can see here so if
you move it it should get the value that
you are currently on and use it to set
the number on this label and then this
minimize button at the top here too this
one uh if I I said that if it is clicked
then it will show it should show the app
minimized if and the close btn2 if it is
clicked it should close the app this
ones so that we don't B ourselves
writing extra code for them it can
easily be done
here so so this is the UI it has this
title
bar uh what we will use for a default
title bar because you realize very soon
enough that we need a title bar to move
the app around and so we remove the
default one so we have to create our own
and it's called title frame inside of
which there is the name m beats my
friend called Augustin suggested it and
so that the frame pass move our app and
then this is the currently playing this
is place where our song name will go
these labels each of them when you click
on them you see that their name is uh
their names are here if you go ahead and
modify this file because obviously my
colors may not be the best and make sure
that the names that you if you change
the names of the labels and any of the
widgets make sure that you keep it in
mind because that is what we are going
to reference to in uh pip charm when we
are writing the code so uh just be
careful of that and
you see this is where the playback
controls are the Hoover effect
everything is done with stylesheets if I
right click on one of them and go to
change stylesheet you see that I can add
CSS to this particular widget that is
what makes this QT so powerful one of
the things let me see that makes CT very
powerful you can add CSS styling to any
of the widgets you see this colors they
all CSS that are used so when it is
hover just change this background color
there and all that
and uh if you are wondering where the
rounded corners of the Hoover is coming
from you see that this place there's no
B radius there but it is inheriting from
this parents that is is inside so that
is very very cool so it's inheriting
from this border radius of the
parent and this is the slider has also
been customized with some CSS just to
look like this because the raw one
doesn't look like this at all you see
that I have to get the groove and then
the handle if I should change any of
these colors let me go for the group the
alpha is 100 let me make it
255 so that be
full when I click on apply so that it
changes this color here so I obviously
not like it this way so let me cancel
out of it and yeah so you can choose to
customize it as you want if you go to
the next page of this stack widget is
this a stack widget then you can see the
playlist page and also the favorite page
but the page that that you leave this
thing on and save the file it is the
default page that will render when you
convert it to python code so we want to
keep you to the song list page this
button is the one that open files you
see that each of them has uh when you
come to the property editor it has it
icon linked as a resource file so we
just have to save the resource file and
then uh we will be good to go the
background image also is
here and then the over lay is also there
there's an overlay if you open in one of
the images you see that the color is not
really dark like this or at least and it
doesn't have
any overlay like this on it this overlay
is also
another picture in the files that just
gives our apps an overlay like this it
even factors in the title frame
also and if I go ahead and preview this
you will see that
so let me preview infusion style my
favorite you see that there's a defa
title but this not doesn't look like the
one you saw in the
demo I cannot maximize
this but in case you want to make it
responsive that is where you use layouts
and Frames uh all of this in pt5 the
containers in P5 to make it responsive
but because of the fixed size of the
background image and the overlay image
that has to be on the background image
if I try to set a layout for this
Central widget which should be the which
should make the app responsive then it
will just mess up everything so if I
just show it now you that everything now
is messed up let me just close it and
pretend that I didn't do
this so I can open r
sent and then we have it back so that is
why I couldn't make this one responsive
and that is the reason there is another
file in there called music. py
music.i this one looks exactly like this
one but doesn't have a background image
if the background image goes off then we
solve that issue because now I can make
the central wiet give it a layout and if
I go to form and then
preview you see that I can
maximize it uh the if I maximize it now
you see that it's it's actually full
screen so you can do that and maximize
it but here you not get the background
slid show so if you like it this way I
think some of our icons are missing uh
you can let's just fix them if you like
it this way then you can of course go
with it but if not if you want the
background slideshow then you have to
stick with the old UI let me fix this
one so we can
so where is the
icon I'm not looking for the frame I'm
looking for this
one okay
so choose
resource I always goes to the second
screen I can choose this one okay and we
will use the same thing here
also okay so it looks
nicer okay so this changes be pushed
probably your the stter file will not
have it but the finished one will have
it so if I go ahead and
preview you see that they all there
beautifully so depending on which one
you want you can choose between the two
but anyways you still have a great
application so that is it about the C
designer if you want more tutorials on
that one you can check out my channel I
have a great project that make use of KT
designer and PT 5 uh so we can build
those things from scratch
okay let us now design the
UI the UI file we use is the main. UI so
this new one that you create I will call
it probably test or any other name it
will not be push to
GitHub that is because I will delete it
afterwards is this just to show you how
to design the UI but this is what we use
everything will look exactly like the
main. UI just that we use this one and
I'll delete that one afterwards as I
said the purpose is to show you how to
design the UI so let us come back to KT
designer and in here let us make sure if
you don't have this window come to this
uh the new icon here make sure it's on
Main window and then click on create
the first thing we want to do let me
bring this one up is to give our app a
name so we click on the main window the
Q main window here and come down to this
place in the property editor you find
window title you see that the currently
the window Title Here is main window you
find window title which you can call
Advanced
music player and that should change it
for you you see that changes in real
time we also have to name our class
itself so that's one we come here the
object name the object name so you see
the objects and then the objects class
so the object name should be
UI no should be music app sorry music
app the UI is added there automatically
and you know that you cannot give space
in here if you want to give a space it
will not really allow you so that
becomes the name of the class if you
come back to py Cham okay when we
convert it you get to know what this one
is usually to add UI to it and then and
that will be the the name of the class
that you call in
Python and so we want to also set the
size of this but before then let me try
and save
it
so as I said let me call this one or let
instead of test let me call it maincore
one that is so close and far better and
we have all the images in that
particular folder but before we move on
also and resite let me let us create the
resource file come to the resource
browser click on this pencil icon and
then you click on this button here to
create a new resource file which will
also call R
S1 and then after that you just select
this one and you add prefix in case your
icons are grouped you maybe you group
them into the categories you can use the
prefixes to determine that but we will
only use one prefix which will be
IMG and once you add the prefix now you
can come here this button and add files
and that is where we want to go into our
etails and then images and then select
everything that is here and click on
open so it will add all of them here for
us and then we have to click okay you
can see down here that all of them have
been added and ready for our use great
so the size of our application will
be 800 by 550 so before because this one
will not be resizable we will make the
minimum size and the maximum size to be
the same so that the user cannot resize
it so that will
be 880 sorry 880 rather by
550 we are doing that in light of the
size of our background
image now it has been Riz for us in fact
if we preview it I can go to top here
and preview my favorite Style
so that I canot resize it but if you
change the size now you can actually
resize
it okay the first thing is for us to add
the background image so let us bring in
a label so you come to this widget box
here usually it becomes difficult to
scroll through and find if that happens
you can come to the top here and type in
whatever you are looking for so if I'm
looking for a label I type in label and
I bring it in make sure you resize the
label to fix the size of the the app
like
this and you can right click here and
then remove status bar we don't need the
status bar we also don't need this menu
bar so right click at the top and then
remove it and now when you select the
label like this you can make sure the
label is selected you can even see here
so here we can now give it a name and
the name will be
background underscore
image that will be the name and we will
come down in inside the property edit
for that background image and we'll be
looking for pix map this pix map is what
we used to set the an image inside the
label so this one it will not be a
resource we choose file for this one and
come back by one go into the BG images
and then choose any of these which I
prefer the first and you will see that
you have it in here usually it will not
really try and fit in but you can click
on skilled content and then you see that
once you click on scaled content it will
automatically fill in the available
space and that is exactly what we are
looking for
great so now that we have this one we
have to bring bring in another label on
top of
this make sure to resize it you may not
really see my transform controls because
of the screen but if you are using doing
it at your end you see some Blue Notes
at the edges that you can use for the
res sizing so this one will be the BG
overly I can actually also rename it at
the top here you can also do it here BG
overlay and that one to we give it a PIX
map choose file and then the overlay is
also part of the stuff here so you can
choose that one too and then once again
we click on scaled content to have a
scale up and so now our background is
complete the next thing is to build the
widget at this right side that has the
the details so that one what we can do
is to bringing a frame so we are looking
for a
frame just like this and then we put it
in or we should start building the top
first so the okay it will still be a
frame just that move it up and let it
fill this black section of the BG
overlay image because we want to use
this part for our title frame
okay so let's give it the proper name
not just frame
but let me do it the proper way not just
frame but title
frame that is great and inside this
title frame we will have a label so
let's just search it up
label the first label let let just
delete the text from it
and that one will be the icon we don't
really need it at the at the inside py
Cham so you can choose to leave the name
like this but if you still want to
rename it that is completely
fine so I'll go ahead and then
choose but this time around I'll will
come into the images and get this app
icon like this so it will give me the
app icon also which I can put somewhere
here and then the next LEL we need is
for the name of the application which we
will also not need inside pyam so we can
choose not to give it any name here you
can just leave it at the default label
two and then here I can type my name
m p you can choose your name as you like
and so we click on it make sure it's
selected and then come to this place
where you see
font let's change the font size to
something large think 15 is okay and you
can choose to make it bold also and then
right click on it and choose change
Styles
sheet that should bring up the Styles
sheet editor this place we can if you
want to add a resource you can add
resource if you want to even add a
gradient you can add a gradient but this
place we want to add color if you want
to add a color you can pick any of these
colors or even pick a screen color and
then add it but that is not what I do I
already have the color and so I'll paste
the color in here the color is this LGB
code so when I apply you see that it has
changed the color for me okay the next
thing to do is to bring up the minimize
and then the close buttons which we can
those ones will not be labels those ones
will be button so push button this
one and you bring it in and so you can
double click on the button to delete all
the test and then you this one we will
give it a name
of
minimize
BTN and then we okay I think we can just
put uh no this one we give it a px map
we will not put the H we give it a p pix
map so come to
Icon and then you can choose resource
for this
one because of the background part it is
difficult to get that
one okay so that's the
main.png I was looking for and you can
choose to increase the icon size so if
we go to say um
24 and then 24 I think that should that
should just be okay and we will have it
we have it then that way but you could
see that on the finished one the
background was not there so let us apply
sty sheets to move that one so right
click and then change style
sheet and then in here we will have to
type some CSS so we have first to get
the class which is Q push button I I
can't really maximize the font inside
here uh but I just hope that you see it
in case you don't you can have you have
access to the file you can do the
inspection at your end so that will be Q
push button and
then we can see that the
background
color we want to like take the
background color off so one of the
tricks to do that is to just give it an
rgba we can choose to make it any color
just that the alpha should be zero and
you know that that one will not show the
color at all so if you choose to make it
white which is
255 255
255 and then we we can click on apply
you see that it applies it and we can
even see the minimum again the the
sign but if we add the alpha of
zero and click apply again you see that
the background is gone because we are
not showing the color at all so that is
one of the tricks to how I did the
background color not showing and then we
can also bring up other things like the
Hoover effect so I can just copy that
one I have up there paste it down here
but after the Q push button I just
like CSS selector I select the Hoover
and then when it is hoovered that one I
will not make it zero I will make it
like
130 so if I click on
apply uh it will not work in here but
now when I close the Star sheet and I
hover over it you see that the style has
been applied let's come back to our sty
sheet and so we can also give it some
pressed effect so that one to a push
button and then if it is
pressed the background color should be
the same so by the border
style but
style should be
insert and then we also want
to make the
color black but 100% but I don't think
that would really work because this is
an image if it was the text that we put
there like The Hyphen that would have
worked so we can skipe that but doesn't
really it's not really needed here but
we have to also apply a border radius so
can say
border
radius of 10
pixels and then apply it and then okay
so when we H over it we see that
particular border radius over there so
what we can do now is to copy this one
by contrl C for on Mark command C should
do and then paste it in please make sure
that it is still indented inside the
title frame that is very very necessary
but this one we will call it not
minimize
btn2 I think this one the name was even
the N was double delete one from it and
this place we call
it close
BTM so for the close BT and let's first
change the
icon choose resource and that is quit.
PNG and that one we now have to just
change the Styles sheet and make it
red when it is hoovered so once again I
have that color which is 255 for the red
and then 20 for
the green and then for the blue let's
make it 12 the alpha this time around
should be 200 and that should do and yep
that is all that we need the background
color I think it should be the same for
this side also so we can just copy this
value here and then paste it
in
okay so now you see that you have that
vle effect also but we have to now try
and bring them to the end as much as we
can okay so our title bar is done let us
now bring in our
frame just position it anywhere at the
top left left and this Frame to let's
give it the
Styles sorry change style
sheet for this one we want to give it a
background color and of course you can
select the color from here so in this
case I'll select the color from here but
the alpha let's make it
and then apply so you see that the
background color is there and we can add
our border radius of 10 pixels so border
radius of 10
pixels apply and that one too is applied
so let us add the text inside that one
will be a label you know there's a an
icon and then currently playing at this
side and then there is
if I open up the main the main
one where is
it this one see there's an icon here
that is currently playing and then the
other one before the other ones come so
this label this one is a label this one
will also be a label so all these ones
will be
labels uh just like that
so let us bring in a label
we will not use it in the in Python so
we can just choose to forget about that
one uh but if I bring it here you can
see that it's inheriting from the parent
and it's also getting some background
and all those ones so what we will do is
that you change the sty sheet
specifically for this label and let's
see that the color background color even
if whatever it for whatever it is we
want the alpha to be zero because this
one shouldn't have a background and then
okay the Border radius we can leave it
it will not really matter it will not
even show
so now let's bring it here and then
select where our pix
map we can choose a
resource and the name is current uh I
can't see it for I think current
music.png so it's select that one and
you will see that it is so large and we
have to expand it before we see so how
we can go fixing it I'm sure you've
already guessed it is to click on the
scaled content and that will scale it
inside whatever parent it is in so we
can put that one on this side and
then let us just duplicate okay we Not
Duplicate it let's bring another
label and then call the test inside
current
currently
clean okay let's resize
it go into the stylesheet like this and
then set the background color
to
Invisible okay and then let's come up
here for the font side let's bring it
up 15 do and then let's make it bold for
the color also it will inherit from this
m so I think I can just open the sty
sheet and then copy the color for it or
equally I can right click on it like
this change style sheet and then for the
color I'll pick a screen color so I'll
pick this screen color from the B and
then I'll give you to this one also so
apply okay and then that's one two shows
okay so now we have this one to at the
top there what we need to do again
usually sometimes it's difficult to get
to arrange these
things okay I think that this is this is
okay with
me bring it
down
okay so we need another label that says
name very close to this currently
playing so we can actually copy this and
then paste and then come in here and
just change this one to
name and then I will duplicate it again
but not now I can now change it let me
take the board off bring the font size
down
to
maybe
14 uh I think I need a board back okay
if you want it fine if you don't also
that is completely fine so I'll
duplicate this one to again and then
this time around I'll put it down here
and say song name goes
here
spand it to fill and this one you know
you have to make it white so go to the
sty sheet and then from the color we
delete this one go to add color color
choose this white and then okay so apply
and then that is it and then we repeat
it for
the song part also but before then let
me change the name of this one to
current uncore song score
name and so after that I can select the
two of them by holding control command
on Mark and then I can paste them down
here and this one will be
path and then finally this one will be
song path goes
here okay that is great I think we have
to increase the size of our frame a bit
so s path goes
here and this one will be
current andore
songor
path then we are left with the two
buttons the add to favorite and then add
to playlist so let's bring up a push
button put it here and then
automatically it inherits from the
parent but you will change things very
soon soon so let's just go ahead and
then do the styling before we even put
the icon there so change style sheet and
then for this one the background color
will be white so let's pick
it and then the foreground color which
is the
color let's try this orange is not
actually this orange but we modify this
one we still need a 255 and this one
instead of 170 let's make it 140 and
then instead of Z let's make this 164
that's the color I used so when you
click on apply you see that the the
testt shows there nicely and that is
great we don't need to apply the Border
radius because it's inheriting from the
parent so for the font you can come up
here and then bring it up a bit maybe 12
is okay and then it can be pulled it
happens to be that we can also add an
icon plus the text to a btom so come
here choose resource and then this one
is the add to favorite so we will do it
that way but the test also we have to
change it we can also change it here
equally so add
to
favorite
great let me reduce the size a bit but I
can make this one to
24 by 24 just to make it large okay and
this one we have to now give it its
proper
name which
is add to
faor
BTN great and then we can just copy this
one and paste it inside here and then
change this now the for the favorite we
you only have to flip the colors so what
is now the background color will be the
foreground color so you can just cut
this
one and then paste it in here and then
this place will be
255 255
255 so apply and then that is it for but
let's also uh this will not be out to f
BTN to this will be add to playlist BTN
so add
to playlist BTN and then we can come
down here and change the
icon
to the name of the it's a music list
yeah that one and so we have it that one
also in case you think they are too
close to each other you can actually
give space manually here and that is
also
acceptable so let me give a space
anually so now we are done with this
side what did I just
do okay it looks like I have done
something I was not supposed to
do okay
okay it's good to know that's a great
scen so let me save the work here I
think it's a caution for me to save the
work and then now the volume dial that
one is called a dial so let me bring it
up like this and then put it here but I
want us to move this Frame up a
bit
great so the volume
down let's just enlarge it and then put
it here
also when we come to the property of
this D you can find that you have uh
okay let's let's let's put the name
there before volume
D here we can set the minimum to
one and then the maximum to 100 or the
minimum should actually be zero because
you can somebody can choose to put it as
zero the single step is when I turn it
what should be the step and that is one
the current value 20 you see that the
handle mooved to that particular
position and then we
can set the notches visible when you set
notches visible we see that notches that
that come out of it I think I like it
that way if you don't like it you can
choose to leave it and that is
completely fine so one after this one
what we need is another
label
on top of our volume
dial which we will call volume label and
then we we man set the value to 20
because that's what it should
be
volume
label and then let's increase the font
let's bring it the sze
up okay I think it's okay for me as it
is
I want to center it so I can come here
down here and say the for the alignment
the
horizontal align H Center the vertical
align V Center so that it will be at the
center just like it is now and I think I
like it that way I may want to make this
one too bold also where is it where is
it
font and then
bold okay looks great to
me and what we are left with now I think
we
can finish the bottom part then now we
tackle the the stack widget
so let me open up the main
again for this side we will create a one
frame at the bottom and then inside it
there will be another frame for the
playback controls and then there will be
this object also or this other widget
also so that we can eily distribute the
space for
them for this
one this particular frame it has I think
I gave it a fixed width for the geometry
did I no I didn't was it for this
one no but this one I think it it it had
okay for the height it did have okay for
the height so let us work on these ones
I think I can minimize itad of closing
it every time
okay so we need one frame at the bottom
there usually it's hard to find here
that's why okay but frame is just down
here let's try and set it
wide and open it up
also
forgive me if I'm not very fast with
this UI building Parts because they
usually take some time and then I need
another frame inside
it make sure it falls inside you can
confirm from here that frame three is
inside frame
to
and it is inside these ones that I we
will add our push buttons for the
playback control so push button make
sure it's inside the inner
frame and here you can delete the text
select it and delete it
sorry select the test and then delete it
and then let's come here this one should
be let's give it the name this one
should be the
playcore BTN
come here
icon choose resource and then
images play play play where are
you that is rather it's rather oh
forgive me the the names are interchange
this is rather supposed to be the pause
but I made that one the play so you
select that one and then you know that
we have to make our background invisible
so let's change Styles
sheet and then choose any color that we
want not sorry background color any
background color that we want I just
that the alpha should be
zero for this one it will not really be
zero but okay okay uh let us apply the
sty sheet properly what I will do is
that as I did for the minimize and close
button so we have to get the Q push
button
class and here I can set the background
color with an alpha of
zero and then also set the Hoover so I
can copy this this one and
then say that when it is
hoovered I want the same color but this
time around Alpha should be
100 okay so apply think we let's copy it
because we need it for the other ones
also they they all they are all the same
so when I H over you see that I have
that nice style there for me but for
this one also we will set a minimum size
constraint on it so we can come to the
top here and set the minimum size to be
30 the maximum uh minimum height and
weight will be 30 each so that it will
uh just be a square like this I think
that is great so what we can do is to
copy paste it make sure that it's still
inside the small frame the inner frame
you can see that all of them are here
this will not be play btn2 this will
be po
BTN and all that we need to do here is
to come and change the resource so
choose the one for the pause and then we
can copy paste it
again don't worry to arrange them we use
uh layout the layout spacing to do that
so don't worry the next one is the stop
so all we have to do is to change the
name here so stop underscore
BTN and then what we have to do is to
come down and then change the resource
icon to this stop and then copy and
paste it again for the next the previous
and all of
them
so next no the previous counts first so
previous
BTN let's copy paste it then later we
change for all of them they icons so
this one will be
nextore
BTN and then after the next we have the
loop one and
so this one will be
loop1
BTN and then we need it one more
time for
the
shuffle underscore
songsore BTN great so now let's change
the icon so when I click on it this is
the previous
because the background is white it
becomes difficult okay this
previous and then the next one is the
nextest then we have Loop
one
which is Loop one the there's there are
two Loops one Loop and then the other is
just Loop one so select the loop one and
then the random
play which is play random but for the
loop one and the random we have to set
this checkable property to true because
they'll be
checked great and let us now bring in
our slider so our music slider so that
will be
horizontal slider
here that one is inside the main frame
the not uh not this the one that not the
sub frame so let's keep this one here
and the name is music
slider
music underscore
okay and then we need one more label
here
here which we call the time label
so time underscore
label and that one
to we have to change the style sheet
make the test
white so select color pick white and
then
okay but we have to increase the font
size
is
it okay make it bold maybe which the
test will be 0
0 0
0 slash 0
z0 okay so this is great now let's apply
The Styling for the
slider
the class is kill
slider the capital S so kill
slider and then we want to get the
groove so double colon and then you get
the
groove and then because it's a
horizontal we just say
horizontal if it was vertical would have
said the
vertical
we want to set the
border to one pixel
solid and then solid solid and then the
color will be the color code will be
999 sorry B that then we put a colum
here yes just like
CSS it is actually CSS and then so we'll
be applying it as we do it so that you
get to appreciate it now you see that
the border the default border that was
there is gone now it's this border that
is here and so we can continue by saying
that let the
height be 15
pixels and then let's apply and see okay
and then we can also set the
padding so I give some breathing space
to the slider uh the handle that is
moving inside let's set the P into three
pixels apply it and see okay you may not
really see it until you start working on
the handle and then the
background the background color so
background let's pick this color for for
now but this will not be background
color it just be background Swit delete
the color from
here and then that is
rgba we want to set
the red to zero the green to 255 so and
this one to
127 and the alpha should be 100 when we
apply it you should see that that's uh
green color light green color there if I
should change this one to 200 and appli
that to be deeper but I don't like it
that way I like the 100
okay and then we can set some margins so
let's give that a
margin of 2
pixels and then zero
so for the top and bottom and then left
and right and then so let's set it that
way and then we can now also say that
the
Border
radius
is let's make this one's border radius
pixels and then apply it and see so you
see that the Border radius got applied
and so let's work now on the handle that
will also be still kill
slider double colon get the
handle and as you have guessed this one
will also be the
horizontal
this one the
background will be
RGB you want a yellow color some that
yellow color yellow color so that would
be 255 for the red 200 for the green and
50 for the
blue so if I apply it it is showing here
like a line I don't know whether you see
it from your side but once you go ahead
you actually appreciate it coming in and
then I can also see that the border for
this one should be one pixel
solid and then the color is 5 C 5 C 5
C let's apply it and see still it's
there but you see it very soon when it
comes in or you know what let's bring
the the value currently to maybe 50 or
something like that you can set that one
so for the slider the value current
value bring it to
50 so you see that the the thing is in
the middle like a yellow line so that is
what we are working on and then now
after that we can see that the
width should be 18
pixels let's apply now you see that it
has gained some some size and then we
can of course give it a margin or let's
do the Border radius first the Border
radius that one should be 9 pixels for
this one so let's apply
it do we not do something right but
radius apply okay so it's not really
applying the Border radius let's give it
some margin so that at least to have
some breathing space for that to work so
margin and then this one will be -2
pixels and then
zero let's apply this time around and
now we see that it's now circular one so
that is how we also work on the
slider for the our custom slider let me
put it that way so what you want to do
is to select the frame in which these
playback controls are and then come and
click on layout
horizontally that one the frame will
space them out automatically for us and
then select the frame if it becomes
difficult to select it here you can
equally select it here right click on it
and then change sty sheet we supposed to
give a border radius of 10 pixels and we
forgot because now if we hover over then
that the backgrounds are square and
that's not what we
want so we can come here and say
border
radius of 10
pixels then okay that one all the
children will inherit now is that the
Border radius has been applied great one
very important thing we forgot is that
the ker for each of these ones should be
a pointer so when you select each of
them where in the property data for the
arrow change the arrow to pointer we'll
be doing it for all of
them
oh okay so now let's select the bigger
frame like this and lay that one two out
horizontally you see that it has laid
them out so let's just stretch it out
and
then let it fill the screen and then yes
we have
our slider and those one so we can
resize it just to fill the space down
there so we can let's just select our
slider and bring
the uh this one we can also set this one
scure to pointing hand that's will not
to be bad and for the value let's bring
it back to zero or even
one let's try Z and see not
10 zero okay for this dial Also let's
set the
hand this one we want to set it to open
hand you can choose either the open or
the closed hand if you go to
preview and then let me select my Fusion
style so that this hand is the Open Hand
and you can immediately see that
something is wrong
here this border the frames that we are
using their their borders are showing so
let's come back select the title frame
first come to this place where you see
the Q frame and for the frame shap
select new frame and then this one you
can leave it this one you can leave this
way and for this one to select the
bigger frame the frame shape no frame
but it looks like we have to increase
the size a bit
okay okay so now let's preview it again
the shortcut on Windows is control R and
Mark I think should be command R so now
you see that the frames are gone and
then everything is also visible now but
I don't want this kind of K for the dial
so I will come here and in of the open
hand I will choose the closed hand
rather I think that fits the purpose
better than the open hand so yes that is
the
great so now let's work on the stack
widget for the stack
widgets I just search for
stack stack
widget and then put it in
here
three sizes to
fill and let's
just change the Styles
sheet for the first one let's just add a
background
color I think we can copy
from the one here but I think the alpha
was it 100 or 150 let's try 100 and see
apply this appears to be too much let's
make it 50 and
see okay I think the 50 is is okay the
the icon the image at the background is
also showing as well and then let's also
apply the
Border radius which all the children
will inherit
from to be 10 pixels and then
okay so now we have this one to in the
like like this still have more space
down here no we need another space down
here for the button so let's leave some
some breathing space and then in here I
will I'll bring a
label for the song
list right click on it you know that
will hear it from the parents so I can
now go to background color set the alpha
to zero so that the text will not be
showing that way I forgot to change the
color bring the Star sheet back choose
the
color make it
white okay okay and then we can come
here change the font size 15 is okay
bold and then we can now
see song list
okay and there are some three icons
here sorry button here so we just come
and say button or push button rather
push
button select this
one the minimum size should
be
30 not not 3 30 30
okay okay this one was the add songs BTN
so let's just add the name so add
songsore
BTN let's come and change the
icon choose
resource and then it is this one
okay so let's change the icon size this
one let's make it 32 by 32 and then it
comes out large okay but the background
for that one in the demo was white if I
show you to you that is white like this
so let me just change the Styles
sheet and then add color background
color is
white think white is already selected
apply but this one to the Border radius
is not really 10 pixel so you can say
border
radius let's take it to six pixels and
see I think it's it's perfect for for
what we needed to do so we can duplicate
this one two
times control comma or command C and
then paste it in here and the other one
name
is delete uncore selected uncore
BTN and then we can duplicate it one
more time and say that one is so delete
all songs
BTN delete uncore all
_ songs BTN great and now let's change
the icons so for this
one resource and it is clear.png
and for this
one
let's this is the remove okay so the top
part is also done cancel the top part is
also done let's me save the work up to
this point
and then we can work on the the list
widgets inside so for the list widgets
let's come here and search for list
don't pick the list view pick the list
widgets and let's just put it in here
and that is so great because it already
inherit from the parents and that's some
of the things that we want you to
do for this one we can add a few things
here so that we check it to can say song
One
song two we delete them
afterwards and then this is song
three okay so that we when we apply The
Styling we will see it you can actually
see that you don't actually see anything
but let's bring up the Fone size
first 15 is okay
then the style sheet for this one the
color will be an RGB
of 86
red
227 green and then
blue so when we apply it you see that
that the song name has changed that is
the name there and then the
background color that we can get it from
here it is black but you want to set the
alpha to 100 you know the parent is 50
so this one will be 100 then it become
uh oh not color this will supposed to be
background color the parent is 50 so
this one is 100 it brings it it makes it
stand out a bit so that it is easily
recognized to apply then you see that
that one stands out a bit and make it
easily recognize and then we can also
say selection background color so that
one is here selection background color
let's pick any color for
now and then let's change it to the
proper one so it is 255 for this
140 and then
64 remember the orange color we used I
think that is the same one uh we will
not see see it until we do a selection
which we cannot do when the Star sheet
is open and then we can also do
selection
color and that one is white so
RGB
255 and then
255 okay let's give a pattering
of 10 pixels for each of the items in
there so apply okay and I think the song
name should be
bold the the font should be
bold
okay you realize that as I clicked I
didn't see the selection color and that
is because let's check it in preview I
think it's because you are not in
preview let's check it in preview and
see okay selection background color
didn't work so let's let's see what the
issue might
be change style
sheets did we spell something
wrong our sty sheet is valid but this
this one I think it it will only work
when we are in
the python so let's for the finished one
let's just add just one song and see
and then now preview this
main see that when we select it still
doesn't show but if you check the Styles
sheet for the finished one also it has
the selection background color and all
so this one unfortunately Works only
when we are in Python that is why it is
not showing so yes we did it but select
the list widget again and then come down
the scroll
area q abstract scroll area just set all
of them to
off so that there will be no scroll bar
showing it doesn't make it nice and then
now for the last thing on this page oh
why did I close out this
widget widget
box for the last one on this we have to
now also bring a frame
again down here down the song list
withget and then that is where our three
buttons will
be
so we can now go ahead and bring in our
BTN which is a push
button right
here inside that frame and this one we
call it
song list and the name the object name
should
be song uncore
listor
BTN for the sty sheet I will go ahead
and copy the color from
here let me
see okay so this is the background color
and then the Border radius I think I'll
copy
everything and then just paste it in
okay it's not really showing the Border
radius remember the frame this one to
let's let's set this one to no frame and
then maybe the Border radius should
apply to the the parents rather so
border
radius of 10
pixels
okay
then the next button is the
playlist
playlist which is also called playlist
BTN let's go ahead and change the color
for this one the color the background
color is green color so delete the
existing background
color and then let's pick this
screen or maybe this
one
okay but the the font size let's bring
them
up 12 is okay for me and let me make it
bold this one too should be bold
and then
12 and then finally you can copy paste
this for the
favorites okay for this one to should be
favorite
BTN and then let's just change the
background
color I'll pick a screen color because
the same as this orange here and then
okay okay so now I select the frame in
which all of them are that's the frame
four here you can see they are all
indented inside and then I'll give it a
layout it looks like this our buttons
then still don't want to show the
rounded
Corners
okay let's set minimum
height to 32 and let me see not not for
the not for the frame for just one of
the buttons set the minimum height to 32
and then you see that it shows so for
the playlist also set the minimum height
to be 32 and then the favorite also set
the minimum height to be 32 great so now
this first page of our application is
done this was only needed for testing
let me edit items and remove all of
them okay so the first page of our
application is
done our volume D is not
here
where would it
be oh okay has gone to the back so let
me just right click and then bring to
front Okay and then right click on the
label bring that one to to front Okay
so that one is it so our first page for
this one is done you just have to click
there is if you look closely on the list
widget on the stack widget at the top
right there is some arrows that you can
use to na so we say go to next page and
I go to the next page it's completely
blank so that is where we will do our
playlist things are very similar here so
I'll just copy this I just need one of
the button because it's just load
selected that we do as well as the list
with it and
then
no
hold control copy
them and then on the second page let's
just paste
it okay and this place will
be
playlist and this
place this particular one it doesn't
even have an icon so let's remove the
icon from there can click this uh button
at the right side and then it will take
it off so we can here
see
loaded this one you don't really have to
give it a lot of the the color
background color is some green color so
let's pick a screen color for the
green this one should do okay and then
the font size should come up a
bit B make it nice
also okay and then uh we want to
increase the Border radius to 10
pixels okay or even
higher let's try 15 and
see
okay that looks good to me but there's a
very big uh something that we were
supposed to that we didn't do on this
song Let come here and then you know we
have to call it
loaded
songs list widgets like
this and then we go
to page two here you can click on this
pages to also navigate and then the list
widget here now we call it playlist list
wigets okay so that is also completely
fine and so we are left to the next and
the last page which is the favorite
page we will also employ something from
here this song list you actually need
and for the favorite we need this two so
control be clicking on all of them
control command C and then navigate
navigate okay we have to add another
page to it before
so for the stack wet you can just right
click insert
page uh okay let's go to the playlist
because we can insert after the current
page so insert page
here after current page and that become
page three down here you don't you don't
actually need to name the pages we use
the index to uh move around so that one
should be fine and I paste what we
copied in
here okay so this
one should be
favorite
and then this ones we have to change
their
names this will be
delete
selected
favorite _
BTN and then this one
will which the next one
here should
be delete all favorite ptn so I can just
change the songs
[Music]
to
favorites and then this one will be
favorite list widget so favorit list
widget the
T
favorit list wigets just like that so
that is the app interface design for
this stack widget whatever page you
leave it on before you save it is the
default page that will render when the
application first opens so you want
to you may have to bring this thing up a
bit okay we want to leave it on the
first page just like this one is so that
is it we can preview our app and for the
preview we can use this button to
navigate but inside python we will have
to write our own functions to do the
navigation and it wouldn't be a problem
at
all
okay so that is how we I built the UI or
that's how you can build the UI and let
us work on the actions the actions are
what will come in the popup menu or the
context menu uh but for now let's okay
let's work on the signals first for the
signal let me expand this want to add a
signal the sender will be
our the center will be our Clos BTN
here you see now when we let's preview
when you click this close nothing will
happen but okay this ones even in the
property editor the curer should not be
Arrow should be
pointer the same as this one
one so the signal that we want from it
is that when it is
clicked the receiver should be the music
app itself that is the the UI itself and
the slot is
close so now let us preview it again and
then click on this one so that it closes
the application so we can set another
one for the
minimized so minimize
BTN saw it here
yes when it is
clicked the receiver again should be
music
up and then the slot should
be
show
minimized like that so that one too
would work the next one that we work on
is for the volume
down when the volume
down we want
the slider moved this
one and you see currently if we preview
it and then move the slider nothing will
happen nothing will happen what kind of
Icon have we given to this should
be closed hand
yep so we want the receiver to be the
volume label the one on top of it that
values that to be changing the volume
label and then we have to
set okay okay there's no set text so
let's pick the set number and then the
int okay so now when we preview this one
and I turn it see that the value will
also be turning together with it so now
let me show you the actions and that
will be it for the building of the
UI for the
actions we just click this one and then
this one let's call it play is that you
automatically give the name action play
for the
icon let's just click this place and
then choose the particular icon
here if you want to set a tool tape to
you can say you can add it to
play and then the next action will be
pause on PA pause SL
onpa capital
P okay and then the icon for that one
also let's choose the
resource to this
one if you can add shortcut to if you
want to but I wouldn't do it if you want
to add a shortcut okay I'll show you in
the next one the next one is action
next and then I can also say
next no next
next
okay if you want to add a shortcut all
you have to do is to click inside here
and then press the particular shortcut
but I I was I was trying to delete it so
the back space also keep choose resource
file this one and then where is our next
next next this
one okay and then the next one on the
list is the action
previous okay so I believe you get the
idea of the actions I don't think I
should extend the video any longer by
creating all the actions because this is
not the file that we'll be using as I
said we will still be using the main do
UI just that this session I was just
focusing on showing you how to build the
UI yourself so that is it for this
session let's look at let's go into py
charm and see how we can convert this
one to code and then start working on
our great
application so let me close this
one and even close this one also and
then let's move to the The Next
Step so I think I shouldn't close it we
will need to make reference to this UI
so sorry let me open it again and then
let me open the main one so let's just
minimize it we come back to it so let's
convert this one to python code
obviously this one is not what we be
running so let's convert it to python
code I'll go back to my terminal and
what I have to do to convert the
resource file to python code it will say
pic5 and then I I bring a flag of DX The
Hyphen X is the flag for the incoming Ur
file so that is main. UI and then
another flag hyph O for the python file
that should be generated I will call it
music. py you can choose any name but
you have
to keep that in mind in case I Call
Music you you call that particular file
name but if you choose music also just
press enter looks like nothing has
happened but if I list you see that now
now there's a music. pii file here it
wasn't here at first if you check your
you see that it's it's a new file G has
told us a new file when we open it now
you see that it has generated the code
for us for the
application but if we run this thing
now you see that we get an error it says
no model named re. RC and that is
because P5 is trying to import the
resource file that we used and and it is
not finding it even though it is here
and that should tell us that that is not
this resource file it is looking for
it's looking for a python version of
this resource file so what we have to
come back to our terminal and do is to
convert this resource file into uh
python uh file and that is done by pi r
cc5 and then this one the output flag
comes first we give the name of the
Python file that will be generated from
the resource file and
usually as you saw it to key to
automatically name it and so I usually
use this name for it so that anytime I
make changes to my UI file and I have to
run the pic5 for command again I don't
have to come and change this name all
the time in fact you noce from the top
here that it tells you that if you make
changes and run it again you lose all
the changes so I don't want to put
myself into that trouble usually you
will be making changes to your Ur file
and then be converting it again so I
just use this name to be
and then so I'll just paste the name
there py and then I give a space and
then give the name of the resource file
that should be converted which you know
from the top there is re do QRC and you
press
enter and you list you see that that one
too has been created for us so let us
come back to
Python and now this red arrow should go
away anytime soon when we run it again
we shouldn't have the
error okay so now it has come this is
our file you see that the default title
bar is there so that is what we have to
get rid of when you click on this one
you cannot move the app around but of
course this one will close it for us
okay so you see that I run from this
file and it was successful but usually
that's not how I do my my pt5 project
because this UI file I make changing it
anytime that I want and I don't want to
be pasting my functions here so that
I'll be losing it every time I'm copying
and pasting it again it's a whole lot of
stress so what I do is that I create a
new
file which I'll call
main.py and that is the reason I didn't
name this main UI
file
main.py the name is main. UI you were
thinking obviously that the python file
should be also main. Pui but because I
have one that I'll be calling main.py I
decided
to keep that name
okay and in here what I do is that I
create a class that calls the this
music. py file see that there's a class
that runs the application it's at the
top here it's called UI music app so I
create a class inside this main that
calls this one and runs the application
let's see how that one goes what we have
to do is to import okay know
from from P
qt5 QT widget we want to import
everything
Q widget we want to import
everything and then we create the class
so let's say that the name of the class
will be
modern
music
player this will inherit from Q main
window coming from the QT widget up
there and then oh okay I didn't bring
the import sorry so Import
St and then we also have to import the
class from the music. py so we can here
say um
from music you want to import UI music
app as the name is here okay and so
after this it also has to get this UI
music
app and then the default class stuff so
we have to Define our in
it okay
but this one we will call the super also
so super call should be
here and inside this we will now also
say that now we've created a class we
have to Now call our window so self.
window should be equal to Q main
window QT we can create Windows just
from widget but we want this one be a
main window that is why we are doing
that and then we can say s. setup
UI and then weet it equal to
self okay this s is redundant move
redundant
parenthesis and then what we can do is
to say
self do
show to show the
application if we run this main. Pui
file this current file it will still not
show our application you can see that
process finished with exit Code Zero and
that is because that's not how to run QT
applications if you come to this music.
py file all the way down you see that
they they call
this uh this so this stuff all has to be
they have to come in place before the
app will successfully run
so I don't do it also in this file and
that is because that's how I usually
like to keep my things organized so that
I don't really mess up with the code
sometimes the code bases can be large
and so if you mess up one it really
takes time to
get back on trct so I usually create
another file which I call
run which will now run the application I
don't want to add it now and from there
we can just see that from Main sorry
from Main you want to import the modern
music player that class that we created
and then
from P qt5 QT widget we want to import Q
application course we need an
application inst to run the application
we also need a system Library so you
want to
import
Sy I was wrong with my typing today
import X Ys and then now we declare that
the app instance is equal to kill
application here we can pass in uh an
empty list it it it this place takes in
the
the things that the application needs to
run so all the dependencies that it
needs and so we can't be safe in here to
say six do agre so that the takes in all
the argument that is needs to to run
successfully and then we can say
window should Beal to the ADV the modern
music player the one that we created and
then we can just say sis do
exit and then you can say app do execute
so exec where is
it this one this is very similar to what
we found in the music. py because you
have to create an application instance
and then run that particular application
so that is what you are trying to do
here just trying to so now if we run
this
run.py of course let me right click and
then
run you see that our application now
comes okay so this is what you be using
to run application
but I like a style in QT called the
fusion style that is how I used to I
like all my applications in C so I
usually add it and so I can now come
here and say app do set style not set
style sheet set style sheets another
thing you want to set style to
Fusion that is great so let's run it and
see of course because this one has been
fully customized we will not really see
the changes but it does
happen I like it that way so now all the
rest will be coming inside here this run
we may not even need it again it's
already in my configuration here so let
me close out from this window to for
some time I just hope the size of the
font is loud enough uh it's enough for
you to
see
okay now the first thing is to get rate
of this default title bar the default
one there so after the setup uh UI
before the show let's just say uh it's
going to be a lot of lines of course so
I'll do my best to comment it out so
remove default title title bar
okay and this is how we go about it self
do set
attribute
attribute want to set the attribute to
QT Dot and we have to import that one at
the top here also so we can just say
from pqt 5. QT so
from PI qt5 do QT Coe sorry we want to
import
QT like that and then so we say QT do
wa for translucent background like
this and then the next one that we have
to
do is so yourself do set window Flags
set
window yes so set
window Flags please make sure that you
check the capitalization also so accept
window flags and then we can say Q T
dot frameless window hint this one
should do for us and so if you run it
now our Apple will come but
the the title bar will not be there so
you see that now I cannot move it around
even though I can close it because we
set that option there other than that we
didn't have any way to close it maybe we
would have used yeser the stop here to
stop it or if you using the terminal
control C to break out of it so what we
have to do now is to write the function
to be able to move our app around using
our own title bar we will need some few
things so let's just say
initial
position of the
window okay and let's create a let's get
that one in a variable so
self do
initial position sorry
position let's set it equal to
self dot position this
one I think it is yelling at me that I
didn't spell something right
okay and then we will have to now write
some functions to take care of the
position that we want to set all of it
will happen before the show so let's now
Define please check the indentation of
this one is inside the init another
function the function is inside the init
so self
it's inside init you call it move
up sorry move app okay but this one we
take in events not
self and then we can see that if event
dot buttons that means if uh sorry
buttons the button that has been clicked
on the mouse if it is equal to QT do
left button you want to be able to use
the left button as I click and drag to
move it around if you want to use the
right button which I don't think you
want to do you can do here right button
okay so now we can to say s.
move we want to move the application and
you want to move it by sell do position
no the position that we set up there and
then we can say plus sorry plus
event dot
Global
position minus sorry sorry sorry
sorry minus sell. initial
position okay so that is not all we have
to add some other stuff so now we can
say self. initial position should be
equal to event sorry event do
Global
position and then event do accept to
accept the particular
event okay hopefully this should do the
trick but we have to connect it
to Something in QT you have something
called signals and Slot like I show you
how we change the label on the volume
down when it is turned round and all
that so this you can think of it like uh
some something to be performed when an
action is triggered but we have not yet
defined that particular action that will
trigger this so we have to now say self.
title frame which is the name of this
Frame
here that moves our
app
dot mouse move event so when the mouse
uh it has a mouse move event sorry we
want to set that one equal to the move
app that we have up here but we will not
be calling it we just use it like this
so let's just see how it
goes you see that it doesn't actually
work it doesn't actually work and that
is because we have to create one more
function that is how done in QT I there
some research on it and found out how to
do it this way so that one will be after
the show
sorry sorry sorry this one should come
the show should come before I think that
should be one of the reason because this
show should be here this connections
they happen after all so the show should
come
okay
okay so now let's run it and
see I'm still not able to move it around
and that is I think it's because there
one of the there's one more function
that we have not created yet so outside
the
init but is still inside the class we
want to now create a function that will
or a method that will handle the mouse
position
so function to
handle
Mouse
position and then we can say
DF Mouse press event this one is coming
in from QT itself you don't have to use
your own naming convention to name this
function just as it is make sure you
type it but I can get rid of all of
these things here and then just put in
events once again I repeat this method
is not one of my own it's coming from QT
you have to type the name exactly before
it works so you can actually see that
sell do initial
position
initial position should be equal to
event.
Global position just like this and
hopefully this should work for
us so now when I click I can move it
around just like the title bar has been
doing I can minimize it I can bring it
back I can close it and it all works
so right okay took some time for you to
go off from pyam but we know that it's
still
working okay so now let's move on
to the obvious things to start importing
files using this button here and then
playing
them so we can call it ad
songs Okay so the method's name will be
add s
sorry and then it takes itself because
it's a method of the class and then we
can now say
files it Returns the returns are two let
me just show you why I want to really
want you to really understand why I'm
doing the things I do so files equal to
K file dialogue this is coming from the
QT reg that we imported at the top dot
get open file
name get open file name uh
get open file names so I was looking for
this
one and then in here we can pass a
couple of things the first one should be
self and then the second one is the
caption so the caption is the title of
the window that will come up there so we
can now say as a string maybe add songs
to the
app okay after the caption we can also
passing the
directory and that is the directory that
it should open to by
default if you put in any directory here
hardcoded directory here like your
desktop or your music or your documents
that is where it will open to at all
times but there's another cool trick
that I want to show you if you put in a
colum and then two backs slashes like
this what it will do is that it will
always remember the previous place that
it's it's open to so let's say for the
first time you loaded the songs from
your music folder the second time you
open the app and try to load uh the
second time you try to load songs it
will go to your music folder because
that's the recent one it have visited if
you change it again now and then you
open it now from downloads when you open
it again it will go and fetch it from
the downloads folder and that is what I
am talking about
so and the next one is the
filter the filter is to let it uh okay
let me leave the filter here for now but
if if what the filter does is it filters
the particular files that should show in
the window the the open window so if you
just say here that um mp3 it will only
show MP3 files for you to select so it's
a way to restrict the user from bringing
in files that are not supported into the
application but for that one I have it
here let me copy it from the second
screen and then paste it
in okay so these are the supported files
that application will take from MP3 to
MPEG and all those ones I also research
about this one and then saw that the QT
supports all of these file types if
there are more I don't know but these
are the ones I found and now we can say
that if files so if files that means the
user can
actually open the window without
selecting files so now if files that the
person select and I think I named it
here fly so files okay so if files what
we want to do is that let me now just
print files I want to show you something
and before this one will work we have to
connect this method to one of our
actions or our button so at the top here
before the show I will just come down a
bit and then now give a comment here
connections okay and inside here too I
will give the another one called
default page uh I am doing this and you
understand very soon because I want to
group things uh where they are supposed
to be and I can say self do ad songs BTN
that is the name of this one if I click
on it you see that it's addon BN at the
top here that is what is used to add
song so do
click not click do click dot connect
when it is clicked we want to connect it
to sell do add
songs add songs okay but we don't call
it in here just make it like this
okay now when we run
it when I click on it you see that it
remember the place of the previous one
and then it took me there so if I should
let's say just create a test folder here
let me call it test because I already
have a new folder there and then for
this time around let me just do some
cancel it if I now open it again because
obviously I didn't select any song Let
me uh see if I can copy from this window
okay copy it's a test and then you paste
it and then let me select this
open and then try the operation again it
took me to this place but I need this
time if I come here and select it
and then open I come again it took me to
this place remember the place where I
was previously and that is what I was
trying to show you and we should have
something in our terminal also that I
want to show you this is the result that
came the first
one see that that one was empty so
that's why we saying that it fils and
then the second one that I selected only
one song you see that as part of the
return it gives us first uh tiple of
this uh a list sorry of of the files
themselves and then it also comes with
another one for the supported files so
we only want this first part of the list
of files so that is if we want it that
way we can easily C for it this place
and just say files comma and then
usually they place an underscore there
sorry because the second part so this
part will be for the first part which is
the list of files and then this part
will be for the part that we don't need
so if you run it again
now
and then add songs let me select all my
songs here and then boom you see on the
thumbil that let me close this you see
that there is only the list of songs
here that we have and so the next
obvious thing that we want to do is to
add these names to our song list widget
that is on the first page so that is
what you want to do so we will not be
printing files like I've done here and
we can just
see self. loaded song list widget that
is the name of this widget here the
first one here so if I click on it see I
loaded song list
widget do add items or okay if files
then we let's now say for file in files
because of something that we do later
for
file in sorry in files then we can just
say
sell do loaded songlist widget do add
item want to add item want to add the
particular file so let's see how that
one to
goes our favorite
playlist okay so is that we have it
added here obviously not in the way that
we wanted it to be because all you the
music players or media players that we
know of doesn't show you the full PA of
the song it only shows you the the song
elv or the song names as they appear in
the folder and that is what you about to
do
next this thing is too large and we can
easily do that with the OS module so let
me just instead of just the raw file I
can just say os. path do base name this
will give me just the name of the
particular file and so if I run it
now
you see that now I only have the file
names and they are displayed here nicely
just like this okay but you could see
also in the finished product that there
was some icon here at the left before
the name come so let us add that one and
make the work complete let me cut this
one here from from here for now and then
what I want to do before I add the song
is I'll add a k list widget
item
and then inside the Kess widget item I
will add in two things K
icon
sorry I think I have to import that from
somewhere let me see Pam on iover over
it like this is to import it for me and
if you don't have it be sure to import
it from
P5 and then for the icon I don't think I
will have
to
sorry this is just redundance so for the
icon I will just passing the path to the
icon and if you come to the resource
browser
here and I expand this side you see when
I click on the images all the images
here I can copy the part so if I am
looking for which one are we looking for
we looking for this one if I click on it
like this and copy path I will get the
path to the resource file and that can
also that which will come from the
python file that we converted that is
how the resource files work so I can
just paste it in like this that is the
path that we need and then the second
argument here being the file name sorry
sorry sorry sorry which is the os. path
do base name of the
file okay so that is why we didn't use
add item or anything like that we just
wanted toate each of them and then add
this one
okay so now if we add songs hopefully
there shouldn't be any error but a
beautiful thing here for us okay so that
is it we have our songs loaded with a
beautiful icon at the side there so the
obvious step next that we have to do
that is to play the song so let us get
into the playing of that particular
song again I will create another file
for give me I'm creating so many files
this will not be the last one but I
usually create a phold so called songs
where we keep uh some lists because we
want to when we load the fil we want to
load them into a list and then play from
that particular list because our app
will only display the the files name as
it appears in the folder but we need a
full part so we have to store the full
part somewhere which I will do or we are
doing with inside
the the songs. py file so we just let's
create two lists
there the first one is
current current
song list and that should be an empty
file an empty list sorry and then the
second one that you want to create so
that you don't come back to this file
again is
favorite um favorite let want be
favorite songs
list okay which is also an empty list
just like this and then we can close it
okay and so what we want to do is that
before we add the file so for file in
file we can now say
songs songs dot uh no
songs dot current song list do append
you want to append the file to it so
that we have it there be sure to import
it most of these uh my that I do the P
will import them for me automatically
but if you're a different editor you may
have to do the importation yourself so
just keep track of that I'll will try my
best to allert you anytime that has to
happen so that you you can import them
so now that we have it imported into
that file then we can now go and call it
and use it what happens is that if we
now load songs like
this when we click on it in this list
widget we can use H get the current
index or current selection from the song
list widget or the index of the current
selection from the song list widget and
then we can use that particular index to
access the full part of the file from
the song list widget uh that we have
created the empty list or which will now
be filled with all of these things and
so that we can use that one to index
into it select it and then play it but
before we can play the song we have to
create a player object or appear
somewhere okay so
um self.
player equal to K media
player media sorry Q
Media
player and then be sure to import that
one also from pqt 5. QT
multimedia we can now come here and then
add a new method that will play the
songs okay
now this one let's put it in a tri
accept block I usually like to do that
for applications like this especially
when the code Bas will grow large it's
good so that your application will not
be crashing often in terms there's
anything that will crashing then the try
accept will save you from that so
accept can say exception maybe as e we
can now say like print and inside an F
string we can try and print out
something that will help us know where
the application crashed so I can say
Okay Play song error so that I know that
the error is coming from the play on and
then I can plug in E
here inside here now I can write the
functionality what we need to do to play
a song is of course get a song which you
do by the index so if you want to get
the index is you can say current
selection sorry
current selection should be equal
to self do loaded song list wiget uh not
this one
loaded songlist widget dot current
rule this will give us the index of the
current selection then we can later use
in in assessing the file from the song
list the list widget oh sorry the list
not the list widget and then we can now
see that current
song now equals to
songs. loaded song list widget how do
you call it it's not loaded s or current
song list wiget
yeah and then we can now access the the
one at the current
selection when we have it like this then
now we can go ahead and play the song
what we have to do now is to create a
URL that is our with work in by so sore
URL that should be equal to K
media content which should also come
from
pt5 QT
multimedia so Q media content then Q
URL which should also come
from P
cor okay and then you can say URL sorry
Dot from local file because we are
accessing it from our computer and then
we can now see the current
song so we get the new URL that will not
be a problem for QT to play
with then we can now say sub.
player do set
media set the media to the song
URL and then we can now say s
do
player do
playay okay this should play our song
for us so let's just in
anticipation oh I should connect it
first I'm sure you guess that so where
our connections are on the default page
we can now say s do
play Play song BTN or something like
that or it's called play BTN play play
BTN this
one this is what we want to use so play
BTN at the top here so play BTN do
click do connect we want to connect it
to self do Play
song okay of course don't call it just
let it be there like
that and then now let's load a
song I would like to this volume doesn't
work for now but if I select life is a
dream you see that now it is playing so
we have done the basic thing that basic
thing that application has to play a
song I can't let me just close it so now
we've done the basic thing let's us move
ahead to now pause and unpause Our
Song so that one should should
go can say pause and un pause
but before we do that let's just get
some Global variables to keep track of
certain States in our
application I'll do them at the top here
so after the player or before that I can
now say globals and we will need Global
stopped we will also
need
Global loop I just creating all of them
so that we don't have to come back and
ourselves and then we need a
global is shuffled we want to keep track
when we are playing the random we want
to know whether it's shff or not so the
initial states of this one should be
that
stopped is false when we start the
application it cannot be stopped and
loop I mean when you start application
stop cannot be false that was what I was
trying to say Loop is also false
here this is not JavaScript is capital F
and then is shuffled is also false so
it's shuffled which is also equal to
false okay then we can now use this to
create our pause and on
pause so
here what we have to say is we want to
we have to check whether there is a song
playing and this is how we can do it in
pqt we will just say that if
self do
player do state the player that we
created out there if the state equal
to Q sorry Q Media Player do playing
state that means that the song is
playing then we can say s self. player.
pause else
s.
player. playay so that is the trick that
should do the pause and on pause for
us not something so
difficult so we come up here do our
connection where is
it the but should be ser. Pa
BTN do click do connect connect it for
the s
pause and on pause so now let's see
whether we
can pause and unpause the song as we
play so Raising Me Higher
Play you can hear that it's playing in
the background if I click on this it has
paused when I click on on pause it
resumes and then it continues playing so
yes this one to has been C for the
obvious one that we contined is the next
the stop so let's just create the
connection here before we go down so uh
can help by duplicating s dot we will
call it stop
song stop to obviously through an error
because doesn't know that one so stop
BTN that's is what
will do that for us so let's come
down
and this one is quite quite simple so I
also want to wrap this in the try sub
blog because as we go ahead and then
build the application a lot of things
will be will have to be considered
before stopping the application
especially when we are playing from from
different places like the playlist or
the favorite tab instead of the actual
or the default song list wiget so let me
just safely wrap this one also in a tri
block I do have some snippet in Pyon
that help me and this place will be
stop stop song
error and here we can now come and say
ser. player no player. store just as
easy as that just as easy as that
so feeling
[Music]
happy pause it on
pause and then stop it has stopped it I
we forgot a very important step the song
name should go here and the song pass
should go here this one should have been
done when we hit the play button so
let's do it and then get that one
off where is our
play
okay after it's placed we can let's
check their
names yeah this is called the current
song
name then current song path
okay
so self dot sorry sorry
current song name do set text that is
how we can do it set text and we want to
set it to it should be an F
string os.
path. base name of the
file and then here we can just duplicate
this and I think it's current
song path and the only thing that we
have to change in
here why is it say oh okay okay okay I'm
thinking that we are in the load songs
so this one will
be current
song okay this one too should be current
song
okay and the only thing we have to
change here is that the base name will
not be D name that is it and that should
fix it for us let's
see so let's
add okay life is a dream play and then
we see life is a dream and then the four
path is done there if I I play a happy
Christmas that
one for now this part is cated for
okay but one more thing is that that you
see that our slider is not moving when
we uh Play the song we will work on that
but let's first work on the volume
control
before we want to set an initial volume
when the application start so let's do
it here so
self.
initial
volume let's set it to
20 so that our volume will be at 20 when
the application starts
and then
here we can say um function to change
the volume of something like that so
function to
change the
volume volume you call it volume
underscore
change
okay and this is where we also have to
bringing a tri accept block because a
lot of things can happen and this place
we can just
say volume change
error sorry and here we can now
say self dot current volume sorry sub
dot current volume the one that we
created up
there
do we call it initial volume or current
volume initial volume okay should be
equal to s dot volume D that is the name
of the D itself so it's called volume d
as you can see here so s. volume
D do
value and then what we want to do is
that we serve set the name the volume to
that value so self.
player do set
volume to self do current
volume no sorry initial volume I don't
know how keep
on
wow okay so this should work but in the
case where application starts we want to
just make sure that the volume is at 20
so I think this line can come in very
handy at the top there also
so just immediately uh beneath the place
where we decare the
volume where is that one okay so that we
know for sure that that is it okay when
it runs at
first and it seem to be something wrong
here uh okay we also have to set the
value of this text and then there they
handle to the 20 so let's do that one
also
give a space here and then we can now
say s do volume
D dot uh set value or something like
that
to set self do initial
volume and then s. volume label this one
the label on top of the dial do set text
want to set the text to F string just to
be save and then we want to set it to
the initial volume s. initial volume
okay let's run it and
see okay then now everything works out
like we wanted to so we can add songs
and then play around with the
volume it is play first I increase it I
I hope you hear it
L and then now let me play this one
[Music]
rather okay I think there's a problem
somewhere this thing may not really be
working let's comment out this line cuz
my volume was not actually
increasing we still have the 20 set now
let's see if the volume will increase I
think they should be able to filter all
these ones out yes it did so
[Music]
okay I don't think it is still
increasing let me just comment out these
ones oh and I I think you guessed the
reason I think you've guessed the reason
and that is because we have not made a
connection you have not really made a
connection to uh that particular
function that we we created down there
that is very very very off things like
that do happen so forgive me how we do
this connection is a bit different from
what we have seen so far and we can just
go self. volume
d dot value change this one we not
looking for the click we looking for
value chain do
connect what we want to do here is that
we want to pass in
Lambda because it is has it has to be
listening always keeping track of the
particular value that the values will be
changing as we turn the out so it have
to be able to keep track of it and then
use it so that's why we pass in the
Lambda and then s dot volume changed and
for this one you bring in the
parenthesis like we are calling the
function that's also one of the reasons
we are bringing in the Lambda because if
you have to pass any value here then the
Lambda should be here but in this case
the value will be gotten for
us the D itself knows how to return it
and so we can use that for our
player okay so now if I
play okay now the volume goes high for
me
[Music]
very low then High okay so our volume
dial is also
working uh the next obvious thing that
we have to do is to get this slider to
be moving with a song and so let us get
to that part and then see how that one
also
goes for that one we
will create another one another function
here to move the
slider
I want us to bring it to this place just
after the function to handle the mouse
position
so function to move the slider sorry the
slider okay and this is how we move the
slider we will get the position the
length of the song itself sorry and we
will set the length of the slider to the
length of the song in seconds of of
course and then we will now be keeping
track every 1 second move the slider by
1 second every one second get the
position move it and then move the
slider handle to that position so this
particular function that we we about to
create will be connected to something
like a timer so that at at every 1
second it will get the current position
of the song it also knows the full
duration of the song and so it
will set the slider length the full
duration of the song and then get the
current position of the song every
second and use that current position to
set the place where the handle should be
I don't know whether I've been able to
explain it well but I think the code
will do the explanation better so let us
get into the writing so we Define move _
slider and
then we can see that if
stopped
return you remember the the stopped
Global that we we created up there so if
stopped that is then we have to return
because if the song is STO this thing
should not even be moving in the first
place and then we can say
else can now update the
slider then we can say if self do
player do
state you know the song can be playing
for a while and then it will be paused
so at that time that it has not been
paused the slider is still moving but if
it is paused you also have to pause the
slider so we have to keep check of that
so now Q Media Player this one you have
seen it before you know that you are
trying to get the state of the player
and then we can just say that playing
State then that is if and only if it is
play if it is PA don't do
it then self. music slider that is the
name of the slider here you see s. music
slider so s. music slider dot set
minimum not minimum size set minimum
here to zero and then I know you've
guessed the The Next Step so s do music
slider do set
maximum to the duration of the song
which you can get
byself do
player do
duration and they all come in handy with
pqt we don't have to uh write them
ourselves so we have set now the
duration also and then we can now see
that the slider
position should be equal to s 12 do
player do position what this one will do
is it will give us the current position
where the song is is is playing and then
we can use that
one okay so in order to let you know
what actually is happening here let me
now try and then print the duration
so
duration oh sorry I forgot the F
string the duration here will be
self do player dot
duration
okay and then the next thing I want to
print is the um current time so let's
just let me just say current and then
that is
the slider
position and let's leave it for now
remember I told you that before this one
work we have to now connect it to uh
timer
so let's come up here
where a lot of things are going on up
here but we can bring it after before
the connection
so
slider
timer and then we can now say that self
do
timer equal to K
timer it comes with pt5 so you can
overover import it from P5 QT call up
here where were we where were we yeah
and then what we want to do is we have
to pass in self here sorry what we want
to do here is that self. timer do
start and I will put in here 1,000 which
is 1 second it measures it in
millisecond so that is that will be 1
second so that means that every 1 second
do what we are telling you to do and now
you remember you have to create a
connection to it Ser do
timer do timeout this is how we create
this one's connection so timeout and
then we want to now
connect it
to the function that you created down
there which is called self. move
slider
yeah again we don't have to bring this
parenthesis so when we run it now bring
up my because you'll be seeing some
numbers down
here okay so feeling happy let me just
play
[Music]
it okay okay so you see that the values
are this value which is the duration is
constant you can see it from here and
then this value which is the current is
increasing by 1,000 so that is the
calling of the timer so you see that
this is 1599 2599 3599 but the duration
stays the same so that is what we'll be
doing so at every 1 second what we do is
that we move the slider handle to this
current positions and then the length
will be the same so it to be like a
fixed length but a moving handle and
that is the trick that we are trying to
use here right our slider we are doing
more of of course than printing it so
let's get rid of this and then what we
can say is the self. music
[Music]
slider set value just as simple as that
and we set the value to the slider
position because that's the current
position
[Music]
and then you can see that our slider is
now moving but you can see that this one
nearly tricked us into thinking that the
slider is not moving so let's fix that
one the time should be
changing minimize this one what is the
problem
here and then this is what we want to do
so here we change let me give a comment
so
change how do you call that on this ones
is it time labels or something like that
okay so what we want to do is that you
saw the the way it's printed it in the
terminal that is not a way that will be
user friendly for us we have to convert
it to the regular hour minutes and
seconds that we know so this is how we
go about it we can say
current current time that should be
equal
to time which comes by with python is
Def python so Str strf time we want this
one and then the format that you want to
use that uh at the top here say you type
in the format the format here let me use
double strings here is percentage
H now represented H percentage
M and then percentage s this is just the
hour minutes and seconds if you want it
in a different way you can format it
that way and then now time do local time
and then what is the particular time
that you want to convert this format it
is the self do
player dot position sorry sorry sorry
yeah there is the position and then we
want to divide it by
1,000 remember it's a it's a millisecond
is a microc also so you have to divide
it and
then we can also get a song duration but
just by duplicating this line and then
the only thing that we have to change
here is the
duration okay so this will give us the
current time in a format that is easily
readable and then this will also give us
the no this should be the uh should not
be current time it should be song
duration okay I can go ahead and print
this one to the screen for you to know
the terminal for you to know what is
happening but I think if you you
understand what is being done here just
formatting the time and then after we do
that you can just say Ser do time label
that is the
name do set
text going to set the text in an F
string so what will count first is the
current
time and then we leave a slash like this
and then we now bring in the song
duration and this should also work for
us let's test it out and
see okay so bring it up bring it up
bring it
up raing me
[Music]
higher and then now we have our slider
working correctly and but for every
professional music player application
you know that we should have the
flexibility of
moving excuse me of moving to any
particular position in the song and have
it playing from there but you see that
this is not proving very stubborn when I
move it it comes back because every
second it is checking the position and
fixing that position so how do you make
it such that it actually also gets if I
move it here it will stay there and then
continue playing from if I un pause now
it should come back to where it was uh
so let's fix that one also that is quite
quite easy we don't even have to write
our own code for that we have to just
create some simple connection for
it so up here I still have a default
page that's where we
are we can let's bring it at the top
that should be self
do music
slider do slider moved sler move this
was what we are looking for and then we
want to take it as an
integer and then we can now see do
connect what do we want to connect it to
I'm sorry for all the background
noise why they just down there making
noise okay now we want to connect it
to Lambda because we are come to write a
function that will take an input so
Lambda and then serve do
player dot set
position I now want to set the you see
initially we getting the position I want
to set the position so that you continue
from there and then what you have to
pass yourself
dot music
slider do value so the value that you
have not moved to get it and set it that
way rather so let's see how how it
goes and so now you can see it is
playing if I move it here stops and it
continues from there so I can bring it
back then it stops and continues from
there
so that is what I was talking about to
make this one uh behave professional way
like the professional players do and so
of course you have BR on Advanced
players so if you have these features
okay so the next thing that you have to
do here on this page is to get this
delete get this delete one and then
delete all to work so let's work on that
one then we know that we are done we can
move to the the different one which is
the playlist and then onward to the
favorite I think we do the favorite
first before the playlist each of them
any of them should be
okay oh we have not worked also on the
next previous okay we work on that one
but since I've mentioned this or let's
just finish this ones the next the
previous and this ones
before okay so that'll be play next song
for the start the idea of this is quite
quite simple you just get the current
rule uh in the selected widget that is
playing and then add one to it use it as
an index and then F the full song part
from our songs. current song list list
and then play that one that is just how
we want to do so and so let us see how
that one go so
Define nextore
song and then let's just say that this
is also a place where we have to put
tricept
okay so next song
error here we can now see that the song
index equals which is the the current
song that is playing so that should be
or the current selection of the of the
song list widget so that should be S do
loaded songlist widget
current
row okay and then we can now say nextore
index should now be equal to song
index and then we have to add one to it
and then we can now see that next song
or is it I think we can get a lot of
things from our play
here I this things should remain the
same let's just go down down down and
then paste it in so the next
song should not be equal to songs do
song list and the next
index so all that we have to do here is
all this we have to change them to
okay you have to change it to next one
so next
song okay so this should work for us and
yeah let's see how it
goes
okay sorry
s so I'm playing life is a dream now if
I play nextest bring up my
volume oh and I know you know because we
have not connected we have not made a
connection so let's go up here and now
say that s do
next
BTN do
click do connect want to connect it to
s. next song without the
parenthesis and then let's
see most of the times when I'm building
this QT apps I forget to make the
connection I just forget to make the
connection and then I'll have to come
back again so now life is a dream is
playing have you noticed that this Alum
is not changing
[Music]
okay and never play
next it is play raising me higher but
you see that it's thetion is still on
life is a dream and that is a big
problem because next time you play
nextest it will use this index to still
play this Raising Me Higher let us fix
that
one what we can do is that after we play
the song um after everything oh no
so let me get back to this after we play
the song or after we yes after we play
the song obviously so we can just Ser do
loaded song list
widget do Set current
Ru uh this one set the current row to
the next
index
so now feeling
happy best and it Place life is is a
dream and then moves the the selection
to that one
and to Raising Me Higher also and now to
take Vibes I was expecting that I should
get an error if I click on next again
yes it is inside here this thing this is
out of range but app didn't crash
because
[Music]
try the TR that we use that the error
for us and that is why I really
encourage you to use that one we will
fix this one very soon so that when it
gets to the end of the queue it
automatically restart but for now let's
see how it
goes okay so I know you've thought of
the previous which should be just like
this one but you subtract one from it so
permit me to just copy everything like
this
and then let's change all the next stuff
to
previous if you using Pon and wondering
why I'm doing all the selection at once
it's alternative J will do that for you
so previous song and here we just
subtract
one but of course you have not made a
connection so let's go up there I'm very
sorry for the occasional background
noise I don't know why they are now
standing they're making noise so can now
say previous
song and then this one should be
previous
BTN
yep
[Music]
so now we know that this are stuff are
also
[Music]
working for the
previous it kind of works when you get
to the top and you hit previous it's
actually playing Tech house
Vibes but it's not selected you can see
from here that it's playing Tech house
Vibes f
now playing raising me higher when I get
to but it doesn't go again yeah
just when it gets
to very happy Christmas check it when I
click previous to play check out just
that and I don't know how able to do
that and not do it for the next but we
will get all of them sorted out very
soon okay so you can see from there that
what we are left to do next is to play
uh have the shuffle the loop one and
then the random play but I also want to
draw your attention to something for a
professional grd application like this
you don't want to play the next and the
previous song based on a selection it is
not so professional at all and this is
what I'm trying to say if I click on
feeling happy and I start playing it and
then I mistakenly come again and click
on a very happy Christmas or let me see
raing me
higher and I click on the next button it
is plain feeling
happy and so I expect that the next song
will be live is a dream not Tech house
Vibes because if we base our Nest based
on the selection then we have to be
playing Tech house Vibes instead of life
is a dream so let me show you a way to
get around that and make this app even
more
professional where our next song is
let's come to the
function and then we will now have to
get the current song and this is how we
get it for now I'll maintain this ones
for now and I'll now
say current
media that should be self.
player. media you remember that when we
are
playing where is
it where is the place we set the song
yes reset media so we can get the media
so this one will give us the name of the
or the that the thing that is
playing and um for now let me show you
why I'll do what I'm doing so
current uh this is the current song URL
should be equal
to current media sorry sorry sorry
current
media what is wrong with my typing con
current media. Canon URL this one and
then we can access the thought part but
let's just pause let's just comment
everything and then let me show you what
we are do I don't want it to be typ in
blindly so oh I didn't do actually what
I wanted to do so I can now
print the current song
URL sweet
next I don't think it didn't mind me
okay it did so this is what we get from
the canonical
URL it brings up a q URL
objects uh it's opening when I click it
is open it on my my my default player on
my system so we have to get this URL
inside and so how we do that is to just
to say the path just give us the path
that is what we want so let's see how it
goes now
also
and you see that we we have a path
here but there's something wrong usually
you see you see the part here that is
running the
file it doesn't start with a
backlash so if we try to feed this one
in as a path there is a high chance that
this thing might through an error it may
give a problem fine we can we may able
to use the OS model to normalize or is
it the nor path what is normalized path
but there's a nor path here that we can
use but why not just put an use Python
indexing to get from position one up to
the end so this one will just forget the
zero one which is this and then get us
from the one which is the C to the end
and that will give us the four part if
we try this one
[Music]
again now super clean that we can use in
our program and so you know that we now
have to compare this
path to the existing files which are in
songs. py where is that one this one the
songs should be loaded here so what you
have to do is to compare get the index
this particular path will be inside this
song because the song is part of what we
loaded so all that we have to do is that
get the index of this this path or this
song inside this particular list widget
list sorry I keep on confusing them with
list wiget inside this list and then
when we get that index we can now use
that index to play the next song I don't
know whether I'm explaining it as I
ought to but I hope and I do hope that
you understand so let us get to the
writing of the code that one will do the
job
better so all these things are not
uh there some of them will be useful uh
so this one of course will not be
useful what we need to do here is that
the song index now
becomes song list which the current
row this current row will go away and
then we can now say do index which is
which means that
uh song current song with index want to
find the index of the current song URL I
this
one is the right thing that I'm
doing no this is not the right
thing it should
be
songs dot current songl do index of that
and that is y so this should do the
trick let me
see
so I will be playing feeling
happy but I I'll intentionally select
the raising me higher and still go next
so if what we did is correct then you
should play Life as a dream and not take
housewi and of course it is playing Life
as a dream if I select a very happy
Christmas and go next but is still playe
Raising Me Higher because that is the
song so congratulations now your
application is professional grade one so
we still building it we still need this
particular piece of code remember in the
previous
also so um where did we get to so let's
just paste it and see where we have to
do the
edits this particular one should go and
this one to should work just like
that
so for instance if I play Tech house
Vibes and then put my car on feeling
happy I would not expect the previous to
play a very happy Christmas but raising
me
high and another did
work so irrespective of the selection we
still have this thing playing out
nicely and that is great so what we have
to do now is to see whether the song is
um whether how to play the how to Loop
only one song and how to play
random for that one I would want us to
modify this next song a
bit
so we will keep this function but it
will not be this and then so for now I
want you to First copy or cut everything
that you have in here don't worry we
will place it very
and then before the next song this
function I want us to
create two more functions or even three
the first one we call it the default
next for now let's do it this
way
and then this one will
be looped
next and then this one will be sorry
shuffled
next okay so what we are trying to
achieve here is that if uh the default
next at any point in time only one of
these next functions will render and
that is that depends on what the state
of our application is so if the person
has clicked on the
loop uh loop one button then it's the
loop next function that will render if
the person has clicked on the random or
the shuffle then it's that one that will
play other than that is the default Nest
so this function that this code that we
did cut we have to now place it in here
so you can say
default
next error
and then safely paste it in so that will
be our default next now let us work on
the looped nest for the looped Nest it
wouldn't be so different from the
default nest in fact if we let's just
say
Loop
next and then paste it in you just made
some slight
modifications so for that
one we don't even need to bother
ourselves with all of this
because uh but there's a high chance
that a person
will will click on the loop and then
make a different selection from
the make a select a different song from
the list other than the one that is
playing so we still of course need our
Canal URL but this time around we will
not add any next Index this is not
needed it will rather be song
index I hope I've not confused anyone
because we still need a song that is
playing so that if the person select
another song we still have that song to
play and
then uh this
one I don't think this should be next
song of course the variable naming will
not do so much of a hand but it will not
make the code that readable so you can
say song instead of the next
song I think this feature oh this that
cool feature in P time I thought it will
help me and let me delete all of this I
cannot use that my shortcut here because
there's chance that to select another
guest somewhere that I didn't intend it
to okay so this should work for the
looped nest and then for the shuffled
Nest where is that
[Music]
one shouldn't also be
so different from this one just that uh
for that one still to try accept to be
safe so shuffled next
error do we need a current media no
because this one we play it in
random so we have to delete this
two and then we can this is it
so uh song Index this one we we don't
even need up to this point delete up to
this point we don't need it the next
song is should be a random figure so we
can now see that the
next index
here that's you're making reference to
here should be random So Random which is
a module that comes with python by
default So Random dot you want the Rand
in we want an integer we are using
integers to do the indexing so run in
and then we have to declare from we want
it from
zero
to I should be with the length of the
song list which the song list if I say
the song list without adding widgets I'm
referring to the one in here so I may
not say currents all the time
that why I'm still referring to
it so that up to the length of the song
do current song list so any number from
A to B it can be the number that we pass
in for the song to play so that is it
also for this one it shouldn't really be
a problem but how do we know
that how do we know I think there's an
error somewhere
like one
arrow in then inspected that
line oh okay okay okay okay I get it I
get it there should be an arrow there
there should be an arrow there that's
what we are going to do now so inside
here let's see we have to call the
globals that we use
Global
loot remember
Global isore
shuffled we use
them and then we just check so if it's
shuffled then s do shuffled
next a
leave
[Music]
Loop then s do I know you've guessed it
so it's look
next
else no I leave
else s do default next so if it is
looped do this if it is Shuffle do this
if it is not then it's the default n
that you want to play but as it stands
now we don't have any function that
keeps track of the uh
changes keeps track or tells us whether
our song has been loed or it has not
been looped so let's just create those
functions here down
there or they should even come before
there anyway should Dobe after this
ones just want to make sure that they
okay I think I stopped giving comments
it's not
good so function to Loop the song
okay Define
Loop
one
song
okay so for this one it's always good I
like this try except forgive me but it's
a good practice I must tell you it's it
saves you that if you get an error in
such an application we be getting close
to like 1,000 lines if you get an error
without this gu it's it's difficult
sometimes to figure it out some of the
error will not even show at the at the
terminal it just says Exit code is some
large number and then you now know don't
know where to fix it so these things
really come in handy looping song
error and then what we will do is we
still need a global so
Global is
Shuffle and then we need a
global loot
Lo
okay and then now we can see say if not
[Music]
loot
then uh let me explain what we are doing
here here let me pass for
now if I run this thing
now when I click on this to check it
I shouldn't be able to click on this one
too at the same
time the buttons have been set such that
they can be checked that's why they I
check and I should have these two so if
I click on this
one only this one then this one should
be disabled so I can't click on
it but if I come and click on it here
still being stop on then this one should
now be disabled so it should just be
switching between the
two that is what you're trying to do
here so if not
looped and then you can say looped it's
not
true sorry
true and then what we want to also do
let me bring this thing down so that you
can have view of most of the code in the
viewport and then now you can say s do
Shuffle um it's called shuffle songs BTN
yes it's just right there shuffle songs
BTN do set
enabled to
false so you can't click on it
again
else
Loop is
false and then
sorry
self do
shaffle BTN do set enabled this time
around to true
so this is the idea behind it and we
need a similar thing for the shuffle so
let me just okay copy this one in
here yep we need it down there
so function
to
shuffle
um Shuffle the songs or something like
that so we want to
Define Shuffle
sorry
shuffle uncore
playlist and then P this in but what we
be
doing uh is to just be changing this
Loop into a
shuffle again with my shortcut
alternative J I think uh that is for
Windows on Mac there should be the that
equivalent the same thing and then here
will be Loop 1 BTN so Loop 1 BTN that is
the name that we gave in the UR file so
if you change it just be sure that you
use those names appropriately so if I
click on it to see lo.
BTN if I shuffle I shuffle songs BTN is
there
okay so for the shaffle it prevents the
loop button for the loop it prevents the
shuffle button and what is so get an
eror we can
Shuffling no that should do and now we
have to connect them up
here so s
do
shle this shffle s bn.
click do connect want to connect it to
s.
shaffle
playlist and then in
similar Mana s do uh loop 1 BTN do
click do connect
we want to connect it to sal. Loop one
song so let's try it out and
see now if I click on this you see that
when I bring my ke on usually when it is
active the K should be a pointer and the
hover effect should happen but when I
bring it is that it's not so I cannot
click on this until I uncheck
this where is it I uncheck it before I
can come and click on this and now this
one to I can't even click if I click on
it it will not deactivate this yes but
you can bring in that log that if a
person comes to click here it will
deactivate this one that is set the the
the global or the variable to false and
then now activate this one but I will't
do that in this build but I think you
get the the explanation I was trying to
give if you wanted that way you can now
be setting the states here so but that
will make the condition a little deep
and complex but I think I'm okay with
how it looks like
now what is left is that we have to now
try the The Nest playing of the nest
actually we are just testing the butons
my songs are not many so that random may
not really play like we want it to but
let's just
see
so I'll click on this and then now press
next okay I know immediately that it did
work because Escape life is a play
Raising Me Higher let me see playing
feeling happy again how is this F okay
now it's playing a very happy
Christmas again it's playing it again
again again again again so now we know
that the random works at least because
my songs are very small if you have
plenty songs that should do
[Music]
and then I think we should check the
loop also so I'll play feeling happy
now and then and check this when it is
lo let me click next it started playing
again you can see that I clicked it not
that I didn't I just put the I not click
I clicked it because you know that the
sler started again at zero but this time
around it's still playing feeling happy
you can see that again start at zero so
our Loop is also working work on it for
the previous
song the previe song doesn't really
doesn't
need no no the previous doesn't need
those things doesn't need those things
but you can also testify that for some
of
the music players we have out there
when the song gets to the end of the
line it kind of plays the next song
unless maybe the user set some settings
not to let that happen
and because we are building an advanced
player we can do that also so now if I
click on feeling
[Music]
happy I just want you to get to the end
of the song end of
the like you should finish
playing now it's
done but you can see that there is still
some one second here to to be Ked for
but in the in the in the memory or in
the brain of QT this is done so what we
can do is that there are two ways but
I'll show you what to work
best the first way is that we can check
so if this time here you remember we
were printing some and um the current
time in our terminal so we can just say
that if the two are the same then go to
the next
song but we just saw from here I've
draged this ladder to the very end I
don't know whether your end it will work
but mine is still showing 227 instead of
228 so instead of worrying ourselves
with getting these durations to March we
can easily write one function by the
help of QT and this thing will be C for
so that function I will put it before
the move
slider and I can
say function to
determine the end of the
song but as I said you can also manually
go around this one and compare the times
but I did it didn't really work for me
because of that 1 second usually that
has to be C for and I think it does it
in microc seconds and you saw when I
printed it that it didn't start from
zero start from 500 and something and so
it may be that at the end it didn't
really match up to the value maybe it
was 200 millisecond short but because
that time time is so insignificant to
let's say the whole 5 minutes or the 10
minutes or the 3 minutes of the song and
nothing May really happen but in the
cases where we want to do exact
comparison like compare the times and
move on to the next song that particular
thing is very very significant because
the computer can process up to that
minute
detail so this function we call
it songor
finished
and
then we need to keep track of something
we can say say
status
here and then we can say if
status sorry if
status equal to kill media
player do end of media and it's just so
so simple like that so that one qt can
tell us that I'm done playing the song
so that I can just say sell do next
song so it will now trigger the next
song which if we come to look at it
suest that it's just we will be checking
all these things and then playing the
next song so you just have to make a
connection
here and this one would
be S
do
player do media status
changed media status change this
one so when the media status is changed
we want to connect it
to s. song finished you remember that we
created a function just few seconds ago
finished great so this one should work
so I'll drag it to the end and I expect
it to play the life is a dream because
that is the default
next
[Music]
okay let see and explain life is a dream
so but if let me just say look it and
see
sorry it started playing again by now
still playing life is a dream let me
Loop it again and
see still playing that so let me now
play it randomly and
see did I click pause
somewhere
okay it's now
[Music]
playing okay now it's playing uh
Christmas let's see now it's playing the
raising me higher so the random also
works and now our
app looks more professional I forgot to
bring anything here to control this
particular Behavior but but if you want
to do that you can add one button maybe
anywhere here or maybe to this playback
anywhere you te
fit and then you can connect a function
sh that if the person clicks on it or if
that part you can make it checked like
this that one can easily be done in here
so you see this particular button
here you can now come and set the
checkable properties to true and that is
that will do it so when you do that then
you just run the pic5 command again you
will have the buttom showing and then
you can now keep track that if the
buttom is checked like we've done for
these ones if it is checked you can give
a global state to keep track of that
also so if it is checked then when the
song gets to the end it should go to the
next song other than that to just stop
but it shouldn't go or like you should
call the um song finish function
something like that uh but I wouldn't be
doing that for this video but I hope you
get the idea trying to to bring up so
now we have all these ones down here
sorted out the only thing we have to do
on this page is to create
functionalities for these two buttons
and also these two buttons and uh for
the favorite and playlist yes we have
not done it because we can only do it
when we get to these places I just want
to do it one step at a time so that we
don't get ourselves
confused but if you have not liked the
video yet please be sure to smash the
like button and share it to your friends
who also might be
interested
okay so what we have to do next is the
songs that are removing and those ones
that should be quite easy to do let's
come
down on the same indent yes okay
so
move one
song and then we will call it
remove
selected
song for this one as always I'll try
except block to
remove selected song error
and here what we want to do is current
index now equal to sorry this one we
need the index so s do loaded songlist
widget
do current R and all that we have to do
is to get it off the list that we have
and then from the list widget itself so
first from the list widgets s dot
load songlist
widget do take item that is how we move
an item from it and we can say current
index and then we can now also pop it
from the listel so that will be
songs do current song
list. um current index so this remove it
for us and then we can let's work on the
remove all songs also because it should
be very
similar to this one just that whenever I
copy paste I don't know why the
invation goes off so this one will be
remove all songs as you have
guessed let's make the English right so
this we don't need the current index so
all that we need to do is
to clear all of them so you let me just
type it
have
do loaded songlist do
clear and then s
dot current no songs sorry
songs. current song
list.
clear but there's one very important
thing we have to do before we clear this
ones we have to stop the song because we
can clear it and there will still be a
media in the memory of the player for
you to play so what you want to do is to
stop the song first so s. stop
song before because if you clear
everything you don't have you shouldn't
have something to play yeah okay so that
is it also so this one we move selected
move all songs not selected all songs
error sorry okay
let's see how it
goes now we have to come up here and do
our
connections it's still on the default
page so we can put it down here Reserve
do delete something how delete selected
BTN Yep this one let's confirm the
name yes delete selected BTN
dot click do
connect want it to connect it to Ser do
say remove one song remove selected song
Yeah the code is growing larger
beginning to just forget things that we
just did a minutes ago so this one will
be think be
delete all songs BTM this one will be
remove all
songs Okay so let's just R it and
see bringing
a and then make a selection feeling
happy it's gone take house Vives is gone
and all of them are gone but this of
course is not the way we should do it
because what if the user was just
testing the functionality without any
intention of removing the song so we can
put some checks uh maybe a popup asking
a question if you want to delete it or
not before we go ahead and then do that
so that's our app will be professional
grade as is supposed to be okay so what
we want to do first is to check so
if self. loaded song list
widget do
count is zero that means there is
nothing in there nothing has been loaded
app has been open fresh or something
like that we can now say k message box
the first time we using this thing here
Q message box do information to show the
user some information the first that we
have to pass in itself and then the
second is the title of the the window
that should come so we can now see that
uh
remove
select
s and then the
next is the the message that we show in
that particular small window so now we
can now see that uh
playlist is
empty okay so let's test out the remove
one and no no no no and when after that
then just return it's very
necessary so let's test this one
out so we know that uh playlist is empty
and that is
great but if we have some in there that
and then this one around it should work
take
out okay you have guessed right this
same thing should be inside the mo all
songs we have to check those ones
also so playlist is empty but this place
we also want to just give some small
caution to the user in the case where
the playlist is not empty it shouldn't
go ahead and immediately remove all the
songs so we have to show a question to
the user and then if the user agrees to
that that oh it's not a mistake I was
not testing the button or the
functionality I'm just deleting
everything then we go ahead and then
delete it so that one this is how we are
going to do
it let's just call it question you can
name it anything I just want to name it
so that we the code will be readable
question equal to Q is a same Q message
box but this one we asking a
question so as always and
then the title here should
be remove all songs disadvantage of copy
and paste move all
songs okay so change that one also and
here you can
see this
action
will
remove
all some
from the list or something like that and
it cannot be
reversed uh if any anything like that
let's just cck the back slash and or you
can put what by English you want to put
there and that is what I want to tell
the
user and here I can now
say continue that means if you want me
to you want me to
continue that will be the
question so we can come down and say
that
if
question equal to equal to sorry that
this is not JavaScript Q message box Q
message message
box do yes if I CH yes that is when we
want to do these things
other than that it will not even do
anything so after passing these things
there's another thing that we can pass
which is the buttons that should appear
on the this popup that is that is
showing so we can say k message box do
yes separate it with a pipe and say k
message
box do
cancel and
then if you want to add more you can add
more let me show you so you can say Q
message box do
no but you bring a comma after
everything that you want to add and then
the default that you want to be selected
so that in case the user presses enter
uh what should happen because one of the
buttons will be selected by default be
Focus so when the user hits Enter key
what should happen so we just want to
save the user from removing all song so
we can just see that now the default is
K message box
dot cancel as long as it's not equal to
yes this one will not work so let us try
out this particular one
also and before
then playlist is
empty now playlist is not empty I click
on it it says remove all songs this
action remove all songs from reest you
see that the default is what I was
talking about now we have yes no and
cancel I can click on cancel or press
enter because it's selected by default
but if I come here and then remove
the the
no I don't I don't even know the
function of it over
there and the low songs
again is it that the no did not come so
if you want to add any buttons you can
do add
them I forgotten all the button that are
there but you can test it and see and
say Q message box dot usually using pyam
or
any editor should give you all this
popup see the buttons that you want
there so
aort set there are many buttons that you
can just go through them and all that so
they should
go now it's it's okay so let's see what
is left now here to do I don't think I
think I think for now what we have to do
is for this page is done except this add
to favorites and add to playlist so now
let's when we click this it doesn't move
us to the playlist page it's still at
the song list page so let's create the
functions that will move that will help
us navigate the different
pages the first one will be
switch to
favorites and and the name will
be the same thing so
switch
tobr and it's so so easy SC s do stack
widget that is the name of the widget
that houses all of them do
Set current index
2B
the favorite is the is two it uses the
same way that python does the indexing
so this song list that we see here uh
the index is zero this playlist is
index uh the playlist part is index one
and this is two for the favorite what
you have to pass in here is two but if
we go ahead and this is redundant
duplicate
this so knowing that I have to be the
tabing again and this's place switch
to
playlist switch
playlist let's just add the word tab so
that we know that that is what we are
doing so s
to tab
okay and what we want to do is
the playlist is
one
okay and then the default page so that
is you can call it the song list T so uh
switch
to song
list tab release
tab
favorite
tab see
to
let's just make this one s
star and this index should be
zero let hope that we've done everything
right
okay and then now we have to now connect
these functions to the buttons that
are handling them where our connections
our connections our connections still on
the default page which is the song list
page that's what I mean by default page
here this one was the name song list BTN
list BTN and then favorite BTN so sell.
songlist BTN do
click.
connect to S do switch
to song stab this one and then we can
duplicate this this and then
say playlist
BTM I'll will be switch to playlist
Tab and then this one will be favorite
BTN switch to
favores no
switch to fav tab okay so let's see if
you can successfully
navigate
now if I click here I come to the
playlist that it's rendered itting I can
click here go to favorite and that is
great
okay while we have gotten to we are
coming to interact with the database we
will use
the default uh SQL light database I will
not be using so think we going to
install the SQL workbench or post SQL
the PG admin and those ones we use the
SQL light and so I let us create another
file sorry if it's becoming plenty this
one we just call it
DB
functions I can spell functions right
theb functions I'll will add it later
Pyon and this is where all our dat
database functions will be because all
the things that we are left to do now is
interactions with the
database and I will recommend that
you get a particular software don't
worry if you don't understand SQL if
used SQL before I will explain every
step of the way and yes so please search
for DB browser for SQL light that is a
software I will be using to
uh view the database because I want you
to really understand what is going on
and so if you count you search it you
you see the first link should look like
this when you click on it it should take
you here in the downloads look for your
operating system and then do the
installation if you have another app
that can view SQL light files to find
you can use that one but this is what I
will be using and so you can also do
that for
now we don't have an the database file
here so what we want to do is no we not
we will not create it manually it is a
code that will create it but I'm looking
at how we can go about it I think we
should have aad of leaving the file in
there let's just create a directory call
it DBS so this is the folder where our
database file will be so this is what we
want to
do we need to import OS here we also
need to import SQL light SQL light
3 it comes with python you don't have to
install anything the only thing that you
have to install was the pt5 and the pt5
tools and so let's just create a
database
directory the reason I'm doing this let
me just finish it before I tell you why
because that will make more
sense PA Jo
I want to get os. get
CWD and I want to join it
to DBS which is the directory we just
created and then we can now see that app
database is equal to os.
path. join noce
link join we want to join database
directory to what to the name of the
database which I will call
appcore
DP dot sorry. DP so whatever name you
want to give it should be this and then
this is the extension is very necessary
make sure it's count so if you are
calling it any different name apart from
appdb that is fine but just make sure
that you add the extension the DV good
the reason why I didn't just pass this
in as a direct path but like this is
that if you package your application
someone know probably something that you
can you be willing to give to your
friends to try out for you because
you've done really really great because
look at application you are building
when the the system they are using
defines path in a different way you may
maybe use uh maybe
slash DBS
slore blah blah blah blah blah what if
some of the parts actually use this box
slash so if you use it hardcoded you may
fall into trouble but if you do it this
way the program will look at the systems
style and then use that one for you so
you should be safe all the
time so the first function that we
create
here the comment will be create the
database or a database
table
and you understand very soon and so the
function is Define
create
database all
database table shop and then it will
only take in the table name
here I want to restrict it to a
string
okay this is how we do it so you can say
con C people usually use C and all those
ones but I just want to make it
connection defines the connection says
SQL light do
connect and then we can connect to app
database what this one will do is that
it will connect to it if it exists and
if it doesn't exist it will create it so
on the first instance when we run the
application to create a database but for
other ter that the database exists that
we have not deleted it it will connect
to it so that is why the function's name
is create database or database table so
I've explained the create database part
let me explain the database table part
and so we can say
ker equal to connection. CER you know
usually when you are using database uh
like my SQL workbench or so you will be
using your K to be clicking things
around think of the K here that we are
creating like that particular K you have
to moving around and clicking buttons
but this one you are not there to do it
so you are employing this K guy to do it
for you all in
code you can also see
K do execute so we want to execute a
particular SQL query and for now usually
bring three double quotes and let's see
very soon we open the database up and
then for now we don't have it so let me
just type it now and I will explain so
we can say
create
table if not
exists sorry exist so to
complete and then I will pass in the
table name
here sorry sorry sorry sorry table
name as soon as I hit enter pyam added
the F in front it should be an F string
I forgot at first make sure it's an F
string and then here we can want to
create a color it look like it like an
Excel Excel sheet so the database will
be stored the data will be stored in
kind of cells should I say so and then
the column name that we want where our
songs will be stored so the column where
all the songs will be sted row by row we
want to call
it bring it open and close parenthesis
and then I will call a song for that
particular column and then the data type
should be text so we python we say like
a string this one will not be a number
it will not be a blog or anything it's
just a text so RW text like we are
typing and then it is good practice that
after we are done what you are doing we
now have to connection do commit
to uh commit the changes to the
databases like saving the changes if you
don't do that it will not save and then
now we can say connection do close so
that we prevent file Integrity errors
in case the database file is being used
by another application like you be
seeing here okay so now that we have
this now we have to come into our
main.py
file and then after globals we can do
something
here we can just say database stuff
something like that appropriate name and
then we can now say
create data
or
database
table and now you know you can pass in
the table name
here passing favorite and that is
because this our favorite and let me
import it so Pam does it for me if your
it's not imported sure you import it and
that is
because uh I think I didn't explain that
part well so when the app creates at
first the database is fresh
our favorite T database table should
always be there because you be adding
songs to favorite even if you don't want
to add it should be there for that
purpose and so anytime that it it runs
the app it checks and the database is
created it also checks if the table is
not existing if the user has used any
other software to delete it it should
should bring it back because if it is
not there to throw errors in our Cod
when we going to run faite
functionalities for now now I see my DBS
has no file in there when when I run the
application close it now there's
something in there which is
appdb appdb DP so let me open up the
database the DB browser software quickly
then we use how we see how we can use
that one this is the DB browser um you
are probably seeing the light team using
the dark team just custom cized it I
think it should be at view I did it
somewhere maybe I've really forgotten
where I did it butuh I think it's at
preferences uh application style dark
style
yeah I like the dark team and then we
can open a database here but let's go to
our directory where our DBS is here I
want to copy this file part for easy
navigation and then click on open
database
paste it in go now it's
here and you see that there's a quick
statistics that you have one table
called it has only one column which is
song and that is
great and if we come to the browse data
tab here we can select which table we
want to browse the data from and then we
um use it here so for now let's let
close connection to our database it is
good to know that the database has been
created and then there's the table in
there so what we want to do now is to
we create the function to add a
particular song to song to favorite so
that we see how it appears in our
database also but before we do that
inside our DB functions we have to
create function that will handle that so
that should
be
okay so add
song to
database
table
I didn't correct this database
here you taking the
song which is a
string we also take in the particular
table which is a
string by the app database app data no
no no no no the database sorry the
database keep on forgetting the a the
database should Beal to the app dat
base okay and these things will be very
very close to each other so permit me to
copy comfortably place paste it here
this is this part that we change so
there a cute we can just get rid of
this and then what we want to do here is
say insert
into and this is uh this is a the SQL
the language to interact with the
database so is just very close to
English more simpler than python itself
so insert into and then what you want to
set the table name you give it here of
course it should be lower case we insert
into
table oh I was expecting the to complete
to do it for me let going do it myself
insert into table and then what we want
to insert into the table after this one
we just say
value course there can be multiple in
insertions but this is a singular one we
want to insert and then we bring this
open and close parenthesis and put a
question mark
inside and let me explain it if our file
or our database had maybe three columns
we put
one
two and maybe three separated by comment
you get what I'm trying to me we would
have been putting them
there but because this is just a single
column call some you just be inserting
one and this is of course also the thing
we are
inserting but after this string we have
to put a comma here and tell the
database what is it that we are
inserting we are now we've told you that
this is the data that is coming but to
which particular column or sorry this is
the table that
should that's the T table if I should
come in simple terms this is the target
table but what is the data that is
coming the data is the S but you have to
put it in a tle here as a
song for the Caps
song but don't forget to bring a comma
afterwards so that's the
SQL this is the parameter so SQL the
code that the database will understand
and this is the parameter that is going
in be careful to bring bring this comma
other than that you get a lot of
Errors it is a single file but you still
have to treat it like multiple or
something like that so that should do
for us you commit you close
y back inside our
main down
here let me just
say um
favorate
functions and this one will
be add song to
favorite
okay that always wants to format my code
for me I don't know why I like to click
on it all the time and so we can just
call it add song to favorite so
DF add song
to The
Great and
here you have to get a particular song
so the current
index so add the song to cover it we get
a current index so sell. loaded songlist
widget. current row
and then you say if current index is n
you can be adding things that you have
not clicked on if current index is
none that means the user have not
checked anything but it's just click on
out
bre then course you can right click on
some place where there is no song and
then the person use out so we want to
prevent that so K messagebox do
information
you can make it a warning too but I
don't think I would use the warning
yourself and then here we can say the
title will
be add songs
toes and then we can
say
select song to add
to you should select the
song and then as usual we return so that
we break out of this particular
operation okay but if that is not the
case then we want to try and then here
we can
say adding
song to
favorite
error
okay here we can just say that the
particular song we have gotten the index
already song equal to
songs so songs dot current song listet
and that particular index get out that
particular song at that index and then
here you can say add we call it abon to
database
table I think so you can see here that
s equal
to import it for
me be sure to import that one so you can
see the S equal
to let's be
safe and pass it here as S and F string
and then we can say table should be
equal
to
faites yes so this should do usually if
it is sucessful you may want to show
some info
here
information
maybe let's convert this to an F
string and say. paath do this
name
song Oh what is
this was
successfully
added two favorates
so that we know that operation was
successful
um this is not a button that should be
handling this request this is not a
button this button will be handling the
request of adding the particular playing
song to favorite but for now that we
don't have the context or the popup menu
to select the one that we will actually
use the action let us use that button
for now
so now we will come away
from uh the favorite let just keep it
favorite so that you know that you're
keeping track of you're looking for
something you just find it easily so
sell do even though it's at a default
page
um okay let me put at a default
page but the button here after this one
so
s do the
name add to five BTN do
click do connect we want to connect it
to self. add
song to
favorite yep so let's just test it out
and see and we can verify whether it was
added by viewing it from our theb
browser
app a very happy Christmas app to
favorite a very happy Christmas was
successfully added to favorite we will
confirm it
um maybe you like it that way but
seriously I don't like it this
way that's every time I have to favorite
this particular thing should pop up so I
just show you that it can be done I'll
comment it in case you need it from the
code to be on GitHub but I don't like it
that way so let's
me load more songs just want to add
plenty things so that you can see have
to
favorite I to favorite I to favorite I
to favorite more multiple times at for
okay now let's come
back open database take that back
intelligence come to this browse data
side and voila you see that all these
ones are there let me show it so is
there they have been added I
intentionally added the feeling happy
multiple times so now that we know that
we can add to our
favorite what we can do is to now load
songs from our database to our fa St
okay so let's see how we load those ones
usually it's advisable to close the
database especially when you're going to
use it elsewhere we don't want any file
Integrity
errors in case any modifications has to
occur it will not allow us so that's one
to we have to come to the B functions
and then the function to get all the
songs from a
particular database
table or we should just go ahead and
then write all the the B functions I'll
will be explaining them and then we will
not just be switching between files that
will save us a lot I think so yeah so
now we can add toate create database
this
on Okay so the next one that we want to
do is so the one is uh want to delete
song from a database table so we want to
delete a particular song that one I'll
hold on to it for now because I want to
show you some SQL trick the problem and
a
solution and so we can go ahead and
delete all songs rather
first
delete all songs
from
uh
database
table
okay the same Bo St so permit me to copy
and comfortably paste it here so
Define
delete
[Music]
all songs
from
database table or something like that
and this one to we need a
table which is a
string and then the
database which will equal to app
database and so I me paste what I copied
connection is the same but
here we can we just have to say delete
from we don't need we don't need this
so say delete
from and then the table name
comes that is all we have no parameters
to
pass
okay okay and this is this will delete
all songs from the database table for us
the next that we are working on is to
fetch all songs from a particular
database table
so since they are almost all the same
let me just
duplicate
fetch all songs from a database
table and we will still need the table
and then the database and we
will this one will now be select
and the column name should come so
select the column name excuse me should
be Su from then the table name but how
this will come is it will bring it as a
tuple of Tes so this is how it will
come a list a big list sorry of T orle
of tle something like that but in any
case looks like this so item
and I think it's the
index or the
rule or some kind of ID but that is this
is how it brings them and for us but I
forgotten the second second thing here
but this is the item that we are looking
for then the ID or some index or rule
will follow so we have to Now find a way
of getting only the items into a
particular list and we use a list
comprehension for that so we can say
that
now um
songs should equal to or let me say song
data
so data should be equal to k. fetch all
all of them for us and then now you can
say data equal
to confer so
S zero
sorry
one of them is missing for song in song
data so as I show you the structure that
will F the first item for every item in
the song data and then we can nowain
this data after closing the connection
so return data so that will come in as a
a single python list and that shouldn't
be a problem to work with now we can
there's a place where we also
get all the tables in a particular
database especially when we are creating
a new playlist We I don't want have to
really come back to this file again so
let's get that function also
done
and that will
be get all table
in the
database and will
Define get um
playlist tables because we only use it
for the playlist so we can just name it
like that and this one not even taking
anything and if you are actually giving
this app database I don't think this
particular database
necessary yeah plus it's just
redundant we are not using it for
anything yes we don't need a
database in you can call use that
particular parameter inside but it will
still be redundant
so because it's just this file it's no
to get it from but the usual things will
go on so our
connection will still be equal to SQL
three and then do
connect we connect the app database
and then
here
also go to
connection there's the execution that
will be a little different so k.
execute and in here this is how we write
it this one we not fing from a
particular table or anything like that
in fact you should appreciate it more if
I do some of these things in the DB
browser now let's open the
database and there's a place where you
can bring a query Builder or something
like execute SQL
here so if I
say select sorry select I just hope you
see it clearly
select
star that means everything from um
favorit and I think control enter should
execute it for
me of course because this place is this
particular software you you may not
really see the tup in T post stuff I was
talking about but if you f it in Pyon R
like that that is what you
see so we see all the things here
retained but what if you want the tables
so that's one the synx is uh a bit
different from this we just have to say
select
select star the same star that mean want
to get everything but from
SQ L
LightCore
master and then we can now say
where
type equal
to
table so if the type is
table then get it for us so let's
see then now you see that it gave
us the favorite if we create any daming
table inside there it will come back to
live let's just try and see the database
structure tables can we create a new
table from
here
let's create table yes so let just call
it
dummy and then the field are the field
let's call it name and that is all so
okay now we have two tables in there we
have not written the changes to our
database so nothing will happen at the
front end for python but if we come back
to our SQL and now execute it again that
now we have two things return
so this name is what we be targeting and
then using in our program so let me
rever
changes yes so now when I come back I
shouldn't see that particular table
again and then so that is the syntax
that will get
us can copy
it and then come back to
Pyon where is it that we are getting
just paste it in here safely and this
will get get us all the table
so you saw how it came so we have to now
work around so tables equal to you saw
that it came as
a this one will turn if we are fing it R
like that in Python to return like a tle
of two each of these 1 2 3 four five 1 2
3 four or five one two three four five
each of them will come in so a twole of
two PES each twole represents a rule and
each row has five elements in it and all
that but we now also have to get
it by a l comprehension so we can see
table underscore name and you see that
one was the second object so the second
one so we can get it by the first index
that's the name can get it by the first
index so table name the first
one uh for table name
table name in tables so that will also
give us just that
particular oh I didn't get
so okay let me just go table names
should equal to
kza fetch all and then this one should
be
table names great so this one will just
give us a list of all the tables and it
will be easier for us to work with in
Python but you can actually see that
this is a very dangerous uh potentially
dangerous code so what you want to do is
to wrap it in a tricept block so let me
just paste this one in here so
error
getting table
names but this exception will not be
broad exception like this we can
actually Target it like SQL
light do arrrow so if there's any error
you should just let us know error fing
table and this one will have a
finally and finally is that connection
do close so whatever happens just close
the connection for us
okay
but if it is successful then we have to
return tables so
return
tables so that we can use it great and
the next one that we want to do is
to delete from a database table so no
delete the table itself so
delete uh database table that will come
in handy when we want to delete a
particular playlist because a playlist
will each be a table in the
database and this one we can
borrow from here or something like that
so Define
delete
database
table and we need a table of
course which should be a
string
and this place will be drop table and
then the table name so drop table that
is how we delete a table just drop table
and then the table name follows that is
it so we don't need all of
this and that should do it for us and I
wanted to show you uh s the delete one
we didn't work on that one is
it if we did if I should duplicate
this no some gets confused between the
py cham shortcut and the vs shortcut and
so this is the delete all so
delete uh how do we call it delete
song delete song from from database
table everything Remains the Same until
this execute
part I'll show you
why now let's come back
here uh hope we have not closed it yes
we have not closed
it we have to delete by the item name so
let's also select uh everything
from
uh
favorite and then let's run it see that
we we get them here like this so is
that's why I added a feeling happy
multiple times is what I'm about to show
you if I click this and then copy it
here and I
say delete from favorite sorry favorite
and then I can
say
where um
song equal
to then I paste this one
in that's if I write the syntax like
this I want I'm telling the database to
delete a particular song from this table
where the song is this you have that's
what you have to pass in because you're
not keeping track of it by IDs that will
be uh uh a little bit difficult but if
if you want to do that you can do that
you understand the database language but
I just want to show this one also so if
I run this query
now and then let's say afterwards you
want to select everything from faite so
select star from
favorite okay so let me select this
line and then control enter it has been
executed successfully
and now let's run this one
also can you see just what just happened
it removed every instance of that
particular uh item from the database so
even if we right click on an index in
our favorite list widgets that we want
to remove as long as that particular
index uh we will fetch the particular
song from the song list if if there are
five of them in there it will delete
everything it will not use that because
we use the song name not the index so
that's we pass the song name in here and
how we get it is that we get an index
that has been clicked on in the favorite
list withit and use it to fetch the
particular song from the list and then
use the list the value we get to delete
it like we have passed in manually here
but how do we go about it if we want to
add a song multiple times to VI because
may you just want the song to be playing
for 100 times or number of times and we
can work around that one so let me
revert all the changes yes and then you
will see that we have
our feeling happy here is that there are
total of 12 rows now so feeling happy
comes
in let me show you how we can
delete without causing this particular
trouble so delete from
favorate uh the song is what we will C
for now delete from favorite oh am I not
coming
back in this place we can see
where row
ID equal
to we can open and close parenthesis
here and then we can now say
select the
minimum of row ID this row
ID sorry row ID comes in default because
the database tracks keeps track of all
the items placing by their IDs it gives
it to them even though it may not really
show it here but it does give it to them
this is you can think of the RO IDs as
these ones are the uh left hand side
here and now we can now see
from
favorites and then see where song equal
to okay I think I should be bringing
things down to the next like so where
row
ID equal to
this
favor or song equal to
where s equal to
this so let me try and explain again so
we are deleting from favorite square
instead of passing the song
directly we want to get all the r IDs
they will all be returned so to for the
feeling happy that particular object
will have the r IDs from 4 to
11 and so it will get all of them for us
so we want to select the minimum from it
you can actually select the maximum here
also or something like that it it will
also work but in all cases we are
targeting to select only one value from
it so if it should take the minimum to
take the
four from that particular favorites and
then it will delete that one so it uses
this to check how many rows have this oh
I got five rows okay starting from where
starting from index 4 to index 11 or
index 4 to something and then okay then
pick the minimum row ID what is it and
it is four okay then delete the item at
four so hopefully if did this thing very
very right if I select this me terminate
it with a semicolon and I run
it okay execution finished with errors
that means we have some errors in our
code delete from favorite where row ID
equal to
select minimum row ID and this one was
not supposed to be
there
apologies because it's not even closing
anywhere so when we execute this it's
still getting us some error so where row
ID okay okay okay okay okay that one
should be here but they should be
another one that closes it here
too yeah there should be another one
that closes it here too so uh I think
that in this case it really makes more
sense so delete from row ID
where
and then which of the row IDs do you
want to delete so row ID equal to and
then all these things will will be
executed so get this particular value
all the row IDs for the value and select
the minimum from it so now I think all
the errors have been fixed forgive me
for the errors and now we have execution
finished without errors you remember the
were 12 now let's run it
again they 11 now if I rever
changes
yes and select everything from favorite
we get 12 but if
I run
this
select now we have 11 so now we've
working around when there are multiple
songs in the playlist in the favorite
and the person just wants to delete one
of them so let's just copy this and
comfortably paste it
here
I think we can format it well
here okay but this one will not be
this it will
be are we
table without a song Impossible so
song but the song will also be a
string okay so delete
from this is where the table comes in
and then here we also pass in the song
that looks good to me and I think that
is all that we have to do here if any of
them is Left Behind we come and do it
but I think that is all so now let's
work on the functionality to
delete a database delete song from
favorite if we have to do that then we
have to Now work on the
the popup menus or the context menus but
for now let's just make sure that
whatever we have our favorite can be
loaded into our application so before
the asong to
favorite we can say
load um
favorite
songs and then the function will
be load uncore
favorite
into
app
okay and then favorite songs so we can
say
favorite songs will be equal to remember
we created a function that says fetch
all songs from database table that is
what you be using so fetch and that's SC
all
songs from
database
table and then we pass in the table name
which is
favorite so be sure to import this fet
all
song This know how you name it from
database I didn't bring the a s from
database table P I'm quick quick quick
quick
quick okay has imported it for me so now
this will give us all the
songs and then we can now
say songs do favorit song list
wiet do clear because we be appending
and why we are clearing it is that
anytime we remove a song from the
favorite we have to now load the
favorite again back into the application
so if there's already an existing uh
list inside the list a favorite list
wiget it it will not affect it the
database will not affect it so what we
have to do is that we have to now clear
it and then add a new one that the
changes will will be affected at the the
user side that is why we are clearing it
before or if I comment it out I think
the effect will explain it better and
then here we can say
self do favorite list wages do clear
list widget also do clear but we will
comment that one to out for now and then
we can now say what I want you to
understand it well so
for
favorite in favorite
songs we want to append it to the
favorite song list reg inside song so
that we can play from favorite if we
want to so songs do favorites.
append
favorite and we also want to append it
the list widget so self. favorite
songlist widget. add
item add item we want to add a favorite
also so until we connect it or call it
at the top
there and we go to favorite we not see
anything even though we have stuff in
our database
empty but what we have to do is to come
up here when we have the database stuff
is it and then we can
call ser. load favorite into
app that should fix it now you come to
favorite see all our songs and
immediately you know what is wrong so
let's go down and fix
it first is
to
where is it
here so it should be where do
path do base name of
favorite and that should fix
it and then they are all here we can
scroll up and down also and yes that is
it but you can see also from the
finished version that there was some
favorite icon here and you know how we
did it for the song list widget
so let's
just bring this one
down okay you know that you have to add
it to a k list widget item which will
take the Q
icon and then we can go to our QT
designer and copy the PA but for now let
me bring this okay I think I forgot the
shortcut let me just copy and paste it
there okay so let's go back look for the
icon it's this one copy
path and
then paste it
in so this should
work let's
see and then everything is now beautiful
like that
sweet
okay oh okay there's a there's a Buton
here to delete the favorite so let's
just work on functionality to delete
samung from favorite and I you
understand why we how to bring these
things here
so add song to
favorite I think this should be very
similar to the delete song from for I
remove some
favorite but I will not copy and
paste so think we have one indentation
in and then we can now
say uh remove song from
favorites
okay you remember we had to perform some
check to when we were deleting the items
from so we have to perform this check
again so that if it is empty don't just
be woring the database with connection
without any work so if this one will be
favorite if it is empty say
remove song
from sorry
[Music]
favores and then we can
say
favorite
favores list is empty then will return
other than
that we want to get the current index
also so the current
index which should be equal to self.
favorite list widget do
current
row and then we can say if current index
is
none then the person has not selected
you need something like that so we can
just show a q message box
here once again I'm sorry for the
background noise occasional background
noise some work is going on and remove
some from this place will be
select a song to
remove from
favorite okay the return okay we can
keep it
there other than that you want to do try
it's a necessary
thing so removing
from
favorite error and here we can now say
song the song that we want to move down
we have the current index at the top
there so song equal to songs do favorite
list wig remember we be playing these
ones from the favorite song list wiget
so you have to remove it from using that
particular list and then we want to get
the current
index we have a function here called
delete some from database table what is
it yeah
so that is what we use here just call it
and then make sure I import
it and then here the
song will
be
song and then the
table
okay and because we want the the thing
to refresh on the application we just
have to call the S do load for into
app
so self. load
fav load favor into app yes this one so
that it will refresh so now what we have
to do is to come here
and it is still there so now this is in
the faite stab so s dot let's check the
name and pleas
start delete selected favorite BTN so
self.
delete selected favorite BTN do
click do connect we want to connect it
to self do
remove one
[Music]
song okay remove song from for this
one so let's
see okay let's let's remove Raising Me
Higher is just one here or life is a
dream the last
one
it is actually removed if I close this
one out we are having an error our app
just
crashed and it says that you see that's
why the try and accept is necessary it's
a databas is lock and that is because
you have not closed the connection to
the database yet so
discard back to our faor select the live
is a dream
delete you see that it did a refresh and
then it has brought in the other ones
again that is why we had to clear the
old stuff from it before we bring in the
new stuff so moove one song from
favorite take us very close to that
particular function you're looking
for which is this one the load song from
favorite comment to this
side if I remove a very happy Christmas
it doesn't duplicate the list
necessarily can remove this one remove
remove okay so now we know that this is
also
working let's work on the functionality
to delete everything from the favorit
so let be very close to this remove one
song
yeah
right just go in by one tap
okay remove
all songs from favorites okay so we just
check if this count is zero fine but we
also have to POS a question to the
user we don't need this current
index we also have to post a question to
the user just to be safe question equal
to kill message box you remember we did
some for the remove all do
question passing s
and then we can say
uh
remove we remove all
[Music]
favorite
songs and then we can now uh
see this
[Music]
action will
remove all
songs
from
favor and it cannot be
reversed
continue and remember we have to pass in
some buttons yes so K message box do
yes they not
pipe and then Q message box do cancel
but we want our default to be Q message
box do
cancel okay and if
question if
question
sorry question equal to K message
box dot
yes
then we will do this trying here so let
me just invent it
in and then
moving
all
songs from favorite Arrow this current
index we don't need
it you remember there's a function here
called remove all songs from favites wa
Rel all songs from database table this
one is what
need so we come
here and then paste it but that one
takes only one which is the table
name be sure to import
it
yes
great and we should load for R into app
yeah that's also that's also there so
let's go up and then connect this this
one
also let's check the
name delete off BTN let me close this
close this we don't need
it CL it's good
okay
s is it delete all favorite how can I
forget yes is this
one do
click do
connect I want to connect it to self do
remove all songs from favorites this
one
favorites then our question comes no for
the first time and yes and everything is
gone now when we close the application
we come back open the
database and
then let me comment out this ones and
then run it you see that it's empty
there's nothing in
there this card what changes did we even
do to it so now let's add a few songs to
favorite
because we want to be playing from the
favorite song l so feeling happy want to
Christmas once life is a dream Once
Raising Me Higher once takech Vibes once
and you go there and they didn't do that
in real time for us why was
so should be doing it in real time but
was it added they were added why was not
doing in real
time it should come from the this
function the we
call oh no we didn't call it so that
means after this place we should call S
do load Fates into app so that we see
the real time changes
okay so favorite okay let me load a song
here uh and see life is a dream I come
to favor and I add life is a dream to
favorite I that it comes in here real
time and that is what we are looking for
so now let's work on functionalities to
get these ones to
play we will now modify the play
function where is
it we should be Clos
yes and here
let's be save let's declare
Global
stop and say
that stop this force it cannot be
stopped
stop made a mistake here
stop equal to false
okay
because it should be
playing and here we only have to check
which of the widgets are we are on and
then we we know what we are we are doing
so if we on the favorite uh list wiget
then it will
be that one that we use for the
selection and then the index into the
particular list but if we are not on the
other side then so it's only this part
that we have to cut for now and then say
that if self. stack
widget dot current
index am I writing something wrong here
current index um let's work first with
the song the song list with so that one
is the first one so and then we know
that this is how we supposed to
go okay we can now say a leave
self
dot stack
widget
and do current
index equal to the playl is one the
favorite is two so it should be
two then let's just paste it and do some
modification then the current selection
is not this it is the
favorite songes current row and then
here we be indexing to favorite song
list also not that one so this one
should fix it for the play for us let's
see if we can play from our favorite
directly so let me just pick a very
happy Christmas because it's close to
[Music]
Christmas and you can see that it's
actually playing the song and yes you
can now play my but because you have not
configured it for the best and previous
I don't think that be a good thing for
us tode here Al make crash
so let me pause play this
one okay so now we can play from that
one let's work on the nest for
the list also this function should be
close Okay so for this one
also
we need to copy it up to where the URL
is this
one and then if
self do stack
widget do current index is zero sorry
not o zero then we paste it because
that's what is happening the default one
a
if
so dot stack widget. current index equal
to
two and let's paste it it should be
similar but with some small changes the
current media is still the same the
current song Ur is still the
same and then the current song index
will change this one will go to
favorites
and yes the next song index will be the
same but this is
favorite
yes this should
work let's
see
so let me play
Christmas
[Music]
next uh is playing life is a dream but
it's not moving
the this is Str it is plain it correctly
but
[Music]
working oh and that is because it is
your favorite song list wiet favorite
or something like that yeah shouldn't be
the actual songet yes and so this one
should work
now yep and now the changes are being
effed fantastic but there's one more
thing uh you realize that when we're
playing from the default this place so
now we be playing a lot from our
favorites and I go next next next next
next you see how it's ROM
randomly chooses we want to be able to
move to the first index when we hit the
last one so we have to just modify this
code a bit just a little
bit uh do we have to modify the shold
nest also yeah I think we
do so let's just work on the shuffled
Nest this Loop n will not be
affected so for the shuffled nest
also up to where we get a song
URL we can cut it up here and say that
if uh self. stack
widget do
current current index equal to zero
should be like we did
before and if that is not the case we
leave self. stack widget
do current index equal to
two then let's paste it and have the
modifications okay okay okay okay I've
realized an error in the first one that
we did let's do let me correct it here
then we I'll show you why you remember
if we set the what is
it see this one we are setting it here
we are setting the current rule here but
what if we are playing from the
um the loadest song list widgets that
means we not be able to set that one to
let me show you exactly what I'm saying
because I'm setting it down here now if
I load a song
here I'm very sorry once again for this
background noise you see I'm going next
but is not changing that's because I'm
setting it afterwards so let me fix it
here then we will come back and do it so
so now after this place
I can say self we just set that one
inside here when it is the song list
wiget but if it's the
favorite set the favorite list
wiget but I don't think we have to do
any modifications to this particular
file at this time so all we have to do
is to come back here and fix our
error so after this we can paste it in
and then we can get
this cut it from
here and then paste it in
here great so this should fix that
particular error for us and
also
we want to work on the when it gets to
the end of the queue what it should do
nextest so for the shaffle nest we don't
have a problem with this so that one is
only the default nest
that we be working on in that regard so
let me
see where is
it so we get
the song
index we get the next
index okay before we just add one to it
let's
see we have to check we can say
if s
index +
1 is equal to the
length of song dot I think it's current
song list widget current song list
forgive me then next
index nextore index equal to Z
else next index next index plus song
index plus one so this one checks so if
the index you you know that the index
starts from zero but the length if I
have a list of five items and I I I ask
python for the length it will tell me
five but if I ask it for the index of
the last element in that five member
list it will tell me four so that is
what why I have to add one to you so
that it can work that way so if it gets
to the number four to actually know that
it's at the end index four which is item
five and that will render five here and
this check will render valid so if
that's the case then next index should
be zero then use it here if not
then just have
to increase it and I think we can do the
same thing
here rep place it with this one
yes so by this one will be favorite
don't
forget sweet and so let's you remember
that the previous also has it where it's
previous where is previous previous
previous okay so previous two has it
let's just paste this one
here by the previous we have not
actually worked on
the this will be
previous we have not worked on whether
it's in
the favorite list or in the defa song
list so let's work on that
one and I think it will be up to this
point can cut it and say that
if self. stack widget do
current index equal to Z which is the
default then paste it in
a leave self. stack
widget do current
index to
two then you can paste it in by I think
you
remember um this should be minus
one and then this should should also be
minus one now this one will be different
we cannot just be pasting this one there
the previous will be
different so for the previous it will
not work this way
so if current song index is
zero you let me delete
it we have to check so if
current
uh no we made a mistake we deleted
something is not supposed to delete so
this is it so if song
index is
zero then we want to say that the
previous
index should now be equal to the
length of the S the list so
songs dot current song list so if
the index is zero then the previous
index is called to the length of the
song list widget and remember that we
have to subtract one from it because if
it's now output is in zero and then it
wants to go to the last item on the list
if you take the length it will give it
to you in a different way that the index
works so you have to subtract one from
it to get the index that can work well
with the list
widget other than that we can now say
that so else
previous
index previous index should now be equal
to uh song
index minus
one yes that should work so this is how
this should be apologies for the first
one have repl it
here okay so this would
work and we have to set the current rule
separately like we did for the first one
so this one will
be the default yes we loaded song list
with it and this one will
be list widget and they should take care
of those ones for us so let's see what
we are left yet or left to do for the
favorit we have done all these things
then we work and then we can um play a
song of course
the the pause and un pause works I pa it
to go stop stops it by the stop there's
something else that we have to do we do
it very soon now if I
play I'll go
forward um
the previous seems not to
[Music]
work oh disadvantages of copy and paste
this should be
favorite so one here too that one should
be favorite list with favorite song list
and this one should be
favorite so be sure to CH change all of
them be sure to change all of them other
than that you also have the
error so let me play previous and it's
working so we see when I stop the song
it stops but these things still remain
what they are and that is a very bad
thing so we'll be looking for stop
song it should be here here self.
player.
stop and then self. music slider do set
value you set the value to zero so I go
to the the beginning and then s do time
label do set text want to set that
particular text so so I just like to use
up strings so that would be 0 0 0
sorry and
slash just to set it to default and then
for
the remember the song names that we set
up there so that would be self dot
current song
name dot set text want to set the text
to song name go
here and then we do a similar one for
the current song path so that would be
current song path and that will be song
path goes here okay that is great now
that should fixed it for us let's try it
out and
see so I'm expecting the slider to come
to zero and then everything else to go
back to and it did work that's
great and so I think now we have to come
to the playlist functions uh we done
with all the favorites at least for now
yes we have we are done and the rest
will come and right it later when we
bring in the actions we are doing it one
step at a
time so on there we
have seate
functions
and then here we have the
playlist functions the first thing is to
try and create a new playlist
so
create of course it's to put it in a
tricept block so
creating a
new playlist error and then the error
will
come you know we have to now check if
the playlist already exists then you
cannot create it so we can now say
existing equal to you remember we
created a function here called get
playlist tables
here this is what we'll be using so get
playlist
tables calling it be sure to import it
okay get playlist tables and
then we remember there's a small popup
that came that you can type something in
and then get the written the value that
comes so without
name this one to rains a second that you
are not really interested in you can
print it out and check what it is and so
that will be
QT
wiget then we have
it we just just import it we need dot um
Q
input dialogue this one do get test so
it's a dialog that will pop up you want
to get the test from that particular
dialog yourself and
then that be the first parameter then we
also want to get the title that will
show can say create a
new
playlist and
then the see there it will be like a a
line edit or like a form field or
something like that
and so I can now see that the prompt for
the user to know what to do is
enter
playlist
name why is the self angry
at but why am I even creating a function
without the Define okay so
Define newcore
playlist
and it should be in there how did I
manage to do that okay so this will give
us the name also and we can say that if
name equal to an empty
string or should be even more careful
can say name dot
STP the person the person just hit the
space bar multiple times you can still
get it so that means you didn't type any
name that be K message
box do
information self and then can see name
error and the actual message
be
play list
name cannot be
empty
okay and then afterwards we
return
else if
name not
in
existing because if the name of the
playlist exists you shouldn't be
creating it again so if name not in
existing then we want to
say we have the function there create
database or database table some like
that the first one yeah this one now we
are using it
again create database a database
table and then now we have to pass in
the table name which is the name that
the person
typed so that should create a database
table for us which is the playlist
Remember that creat a column call songs
and that is what we
use we have a function to load playlists
so s.
[Music]
load
playlist that should the fun that's the
function that we should write
and let me comment it out for
now so if name is not inexistent that is
what will happen but if the name is in
existent and the person still wants to
create it then the person wants to
overwrite the one that is there we can
give the person chance to do that so
a name
in
existing we can through a
caution I think we can get a question
one of those questions from
here but this one we name it
caution
and then this place will
be
replace
playlist and this action
will um no no this this is not this
should not be the syntax
so you can
see uh
playlist with
name
yeah
name I was trying to play SM with Pyon
but it didn't give me the F so I have to
bring it here myself with name name
exists so
already
exist do you want to place it so in that
case the user wants to replace it and
yes our options remain the
same maybe you can put the name in
double
quotes if message is yes then we
can or the person chooses yes then we
can there's one function called delete
database table it should be down there
this
one you have to first delete the
table the table name in this case will
be name because they will be the
same and let's be sure to import it so
you delete the table the database table
and then we want to create database or
database table which and again we will
create it as F name
okay and then ourself will load playlist
should be here
again
okay that should do and so let's quickly
create that function the self. load
playlist it should be the top let's
see so
load
playlist
into
H find so loore
playlist oh it shouldn't be shouldn't be
that that way you find this at s will
come in
here okay so all our playlist should
should be equal to get playlist tables
remember that one and then
playlist do remove I want to remove the
favorites from
it but it's not part it's not part of
the users playlist it's a default one so
self
do playlist list wiget
here do clear you understand why you
should be doing these things the
clearing and then after that we can see
that
for
playlist in
playlist and this one to you add an an
icon plus the playlist itself so I
believe that we've done it two times so
I can type it straight forward without
further
explanations so s
do
play let L reg do add item
and that will still be a k list wiget
item the first one being a k
icon which we copy the PA and paste soon
but this one we are just placing the
playlist inside just like that so let's
get the icon from
here think it should be this one which
one I think it's this
yep copy it and then paste it in there
so that should do it for us yep M
anytime we need to to load it for us so
let's come at the top here and then
connect the new playlist and we have
another one yet no let's un comment this
and then let's un comment this one too
so we can come up here and just as we
call the load playlist into app let's
call the self.
load load
um
playlist
and for the connection let's create one
for
playlist the serve
do I think it should be ising new
playlist ptn yep it should be this one
do
click do
connect want to connect to self do uh we
will call it in something new playlist I
think it's this one yep so this is it
let's try it out and
see if it works we should have the
database table let's see let's see first
if we have closed closed the connection
and so playlist side create new you see
the popup that came this we call
test we press enter and then we see test
here with a beautiful icon fantastic so
if if we close our app and then come
back here open
database you have more than one table
now if you browse the structure you see
the test is already there great so let's
close come back here now we know that
that one is working and so let's go
ahead with the rest of the database
functions that we need to do okay so now
let's work on the deleting of a
playlist so
delete
uh
play
list which should be so the particular
playlist that we want to
delete should we go to self do
playlist uh list wiget this
one dot current
item yeah this one not the current the
current item do text because we want the
text not the not the index so this one
will give us the text of whatever is in
that particular line of the list wi
it so in this case if the name of the
playlist is test to give us TST as we
expect and then I'll try because it's
necessary and say maybe
deleting playlist error here you can
just say delete database table and then
you pass in the particular
playlist so we test so we don't have to
convert with strings strings
strings and this one to have a finally
whatever happens we want
to self. load
playlist so this one will delete a
single playlist let's work on the
deleting of many playlist
so
delete
all
playlist and then this one we should
still get the playlist all the playlist
and see let's
see we got all the playlist and then
because we need the Nam to delete the
database from the database we using this
function because we still need the name
so uh Define
delete
all
playlist
okay and then we can now say playlist
equal to get playlist tables and then
playlist do
remove want to remove the favorite
favorite
okay and then after we remove the
favorite we want toat this one
okay I remove the favorite what we want
to do is bring a caution I think we
already copied that one somewhere know
should be in
my yep here
so yes still be
caution first we want to caution you
that you are doing something that is
irreversible so the caution will be
delete this one delete your playlist so
delete
all playlist and this action will delete
all playlist Del
will
delete
all playlist and it cannot be reversed
continue yes or no or cancel so if that
is the case if the question is yes
you want to
try we deleting all
playlist
Arrow other than that
we want to say
for
playlist playlist in
playlist
delete database table
playlist so it will just look through
and delete each of them one by one and
as you have guessed there should be our
finally block
here load playlist y that should also be
it and let's see how we can add a
particular song to
playlist a
playlist well I just want us to create
all of them then we will do the
connection that will be
faster but I'm hope I'm explaining
things as these things as they are
supposed to be explained so add a
song to a
playlist
okay
uh
you remember in the demo when we are
adding a song to a
playlist uh what we call a drop down if
you are coming from web development or a
combo box if you are this python time
from T this place I think is also called
a combo box but in web terms it's a drop
down
that contains all the existing
database
favorites so we have to get those ones
and then let the user select which of
them you want they want to add the songs
to and it's quite quite easy so we can
just say options equal
to get playlist tables this function is
really
helpful and then options do
remove
remove want to
favorites because person always options
the person wants to add it to the F use
add to fate
rather and let me let me skip that part
or let me let me do it
options do
insert at the zero
position this particular string which
is
click
to
select it I'll tell you what it does but
let me comment it now you can leave
yours un commented and we can see that
playlist remember how we got the
particular playlist here where is it
should be somewhere close
here yeah this
one let's copy this up come
back and then paste it in so instead of
name this will be
playlist you in put
dialog.
[Music]
get item rather they should be get item
not test and then
self yes and then this will be add
song to playlist and here will not pass
you can just
say
choose the
desired
playlist and you know we have to pass in
the options also so we can say
options and then
editable should be false you don't want
that to be able to edit the content in
there
Y and so
so let's see and so for this one let
me connect it here I know we are
skipping ahead of it we wanted to do
everything at once but let me connect it
and
then so that will be self
do add song Sorry add
song to a playlist it should be a button
or something no let's see
okay that is an
action so what we will do is that we
will link it to the load selected now
then we will change it later so
load selected playlist
BTN do click do
connect
to self
do add song to a playlist so that you
see how the popup comes and I'll show
you what I was talking
about or if
uh what is it I click on this thing now
you see that test is the one that comes
first I don't want it to always be so so
that's why this
uh
it's inserted so when this is inserted
this is how it will
come so click to select then we now can
select test and that is I think this is
really cool and so once we get it now
you have to perform some checks so
if playlist equal to this click to
select
here that means the person did not
anything
let's just make sure that everything is
as exactly as that then it means the
person did not select anything so we can
Now show some info Q message box do
info and it be add not s add
s
to
playlist and we can now say
no
playlist uh was
selected and then
afterwards we are not adding anything
again we can
just what is this one doing
here we can just
return other than that that means if
there is some selection then we want to
do with the
tricept and here we can see
that current
say uh index should be equal to self do
loaded songl reg no loed songl current
row this how we need a current row and
then the song should be equal to songs
do current song list we want it at the
current
index
and
yes why we are doing this TR and accept
is if it doesn't work we can show an
error here instead of the uh printing
the
that means this place there no song was
selected so we can just say no
song was selected Ian the person just
decided to trigger the action without
selecting the song so you can now say
unsuccessful or something like
that let no song was selected great and
then after that we want to
return I can just bring this one up
just to save a line and do same for this
place
also but if all the above passes then we
want
to add some to database
table and then we now pass in first the
song which is equal to
song and then the
table which is we got to
playlist so select a song and then the
playlist
great and then we know that we have to
load playlist into
yourself do load playlist into app but
if you want to also show a successful
message like we did for adding the song
to favorite you can do that but I don't
want to do that here okay the next on
the list is
to uh now we have add a song to playlist
the next on the list is to add all
current songs to a playlist so in case
all the songs that are playing want to
add them to the playlist we can go ahead
and then do that
so sh on the same liation level add
all current
songs to
a
playlist
for this
one this should be very similar to this
at least to some
extent so we can
just paste it
in where is
it
after this return you need
it but it's just a similar things we be
doing
here so that is it choose the playlist
and of that if that is the case
and yeah yeah that check is necessary so
we can say that if
length of songs do current
song
is less than
one or zero that means that there's no
songs loaded because we can also use the
list wiget to check but we can also use
the this list to check because when it
is loaded it will be loaded into that
one also then we want to show an
information so Q message box do
information
so and then say here
add
songs to
playlist and then in here we can say
song
list is
empty once again
return other than that then it means we
have some songs in there so we can say
for song in
songs.
current not
on in
songs. current list what we want to do
is to add song to database table and
then the
song equal to
song and then the
table equal to
playlist and that should do after that
we have have to call the loading of the
list so s do load not look
load playlist so that will also do for
the uh adding all songs to the playlist
check if it is empty if not then for
each of the songs just add it to the
playlist and so we can also add a
currently playing to the playlist
Also let's work on that
one
so are
currently playing
to
uh
playlist
okay
now this one because we are adding the
currently playing we have to check
whether the song is even playing in the
first
place so if not
self.
player. state
equal to Q Media
Player playing state that means it's not
playing then we can now show that Q
message
box do
information and then we will see in here
that uh we
add up current
song two
playlist and we can see here
that no song
is playing in
Q
yep and after that we
return but if that is not the case
then I think it's similar to the ad on
to playlist up here we have to get this
option we have to let a person choose
the desired
playlist and if this you can see no
playlist was
selected and then we
can yeah so for this place you let's
copy let's copy after to this return
course we have to do things a little
differently
there we still have to get the playlist
and the dropdown also that is why so to
choose the desired playlist and all but
if this All Passes then the
current media that we want to add will
now be equal to self. player do
media and I hope you remember this from
a previous one those so now the song
actually will
be current media do Canon URL you want
to get the path and remember that you
have to get it from the first index up
to the last
okay and then now we can comfortably add
song to playlist or the database table
where the
song equal to song and then the
table equals to uh equal to
playlist
yeah and as usual
s. load
playlist and we also want to probably
load the content of a playlist to the
song list with it so let's work on that
function
and then we'll be left with one more
function for our playlist so load
playlist
songs to current
list
okay way I try accept
so
loading this one will take
in the playlist
itself yes so here will
be loading
songs
from playlist as a playlist name
and then we can fix this in here
playlist
errow
okay we can see that the playlist
songs
play list songs as the the songs in the
playlist equal to fetch all songs from
database table remember this function
and the the table we are targeting is
the
playlist that's the name so we just
passing the name say if
the length
of uh
playlist
songs is
zero we don't have to bother ourselves
continuing we can just immediately say
that self as
always and then here it can be load
playlist
song
and this place we can make
it playlist is empty so that we just
tell the person that the playlist is
empty and of course we
return and if that is not the case then
that means if the length is more than
zero then
for song
in playlist songs you already know what
you want to do songs dot sorry do
current list do append
song and then afterwards self do
loaded
Lo song list
do add
item you know that supposed to be a k
list wiget item which will first take in
the Q
icon know this
one icon we will copy and P the pass
very soon but the next is the os. path
do base name of the song just like we
are loading it fresh from our computer
but this place let's get
the I have really
forgotten the particular icon we
used but I think it should be the this
one yes it should be that
one but that will also load all the
songs into the current song list for
us and for now that is all we can do for
now for the playlist so until what is
left now we cannot do it now until we
get to some other place let's
also I think for the playlist as set we
create the actions we cannot really
canot
really add so many things here apart
from removing selected removing all and
then loading
selected okay even if you do that you
cannot really add a song to the playlist
so let's let's still connect them so
that we
don't get confused know that we are done
with
it playlist sh we
here so this one is load you have to
connect it to
load and
load
playlist songs to current but remember
we have to pass in we have to pass in
the particular playlist of Interest so
we let bring this one to the next line
we have to pass in
Lambda because we are come to pass in
some arguments or parameter also so we
have to now pass in the particular
playlist that we want to load and which
would be equal to self dot playlist
which is
do current
item do
text so let me space everything else
neatly this text should
also okay so this is what we have to
do but you know when the app run when
run our app now we will get an
error oh okay okay okay okay it didn't
really give the
error but when you click on load
selected that it's giving us an
error okay so there just instance that
the person may not really select the
playlist but to click on it so let's
just wrap it in the TR accept
block this one we not add any exception
just pass it okay so in this case when
we come here we are still good to go is
it still closing
why is it
closing i l should close why is it
closing obviously not from this one
because a try accept have let me just
see so playlist is Mt is
working is that when you click on it it
does without any
selection doesn't give us any warning
but
closes let's see whether there's this is
one of the places
where these errors are difficult to fix
I don't really know why but you let's
finish the app we just still test it and
see if it behaves that way then we know
how to see how we can deug
it okay but at least we know that if
there was something in there it would
load it for us that one we know and then
we also have to connect the remove
selected and all so self do
remove selected playlist BTN do
click do
connect you want to connect it to self
do we call delete playlist
Y and then there's another one that we
created also for the removal of our
playlist as weel
do remove or playlist BN dot
click do connect want to connect it to
self
do
delete all
playlist and then the other one that we
have to do is the adding of a song to a
playlist so self.
add add to playlist BT and this one do
click
dot connect remember we created one that
will add a current song to playlist so
s.
add song to
playlist is I currently playing to
playlist this
one yep that's one to will do for us so
that means that we can add a song to
playlist if we start playing it
here feeling
happy add to
playlist I oh sorry I've had many times
I just thinking that I'm clicking on the
out to playist so it says I choose test
okay only one way to confirm
this is to for now come here hope open
the
database and then go to browse data and
then change this from to test and you
see that the song is in there now if we
close our
database run our
app and then come to this playlist
select it and load you will see that it
it will actually load it here you can
click on it and play and it will work so
that is great let us move on on to there
are a lot of things at the faite side
that we did not do let us complete all
of them and then take our hands
off so let's
see any of this wants to link us to
favorite I think we only
created remove from favorites and then
remove all we also have able to add the
songs to favorites let's see what we are
yet to
do
so we can add a song to favorit We can
load the favorite into
app
and you don't have functions to add all
songs to faite you have function to
remove
song so let's work on the add all songs
to
favorites
here
so we can check so
if the length
of songs do current song list it's less
than one like we did for the
playlist or let's just make it equal to
you can make it equal to zero or less
than one then Q message
box do
information self as
always
um here will be add
song have
songs to
favorite
no favorite is it favorite or favorit
any of them and we can now here say that
no
songs have
been loaded
great and then we
return but if that is not the case then
for
song in songs
dot current song list what we want to do
is add song to database table and then
we have the
song then the table will be
favorit is favorites or favorite I think
it's favorit with an
S uh yep I think
so and you remember we have to load a
favorite into app so s. load
favores into app this one so now we have
the function to add all songs to
favorites
also remove song from favorite do you
have that
one remove one song from
favorite we also have remove all songs
from favorites now I think we have all
we need for the favorites
yes we
do okay so let's see which ones have we
not connected
it the F
side yes we
do
so for the add all songs to fa you
cannot test it now because you don't
have the context menu yet so I think the
obvious the next obvious thing for us to
do is to create the context menus so
that we can test out all these functions
that we are writing so back
here down there we
can uh let me just check the ination so
we can now create our context
menus
okay the first one that we will create
is the
playlist context menu
a context menu is this I've been talking
about this a lot this right click you
see when I right click this thing that
popped out that's what we call a context
menu okay so for the
playlist this is how we okay should be a
function so Define
playlist
context
menu
okay and then we now see that self.
playlist list wi this
one do
set context menu policy
to
qt.
action actions context menu because we
want to add actions to it the actions
here that were created in our file here
I showed you earlier in the
video this actions want to add them
okay and then we can see self do
playlist list widget
again do add
action now I have to add the action
before so self
do action let's start with the load
selected
playlist and then let's add a separator
so we can say
separator equal to kill
action this one we have to call it yep
and then passing s don't
forget
okay and then we can say SE
paror do set
separator quite weird and we can now say
true sorry
true okay then the rest will be
following so we can now say s that is if
you want to add you see this place uh
there this lines that that separates
them that's the separator if you want to
add it fine if you don't want to you can
just keep it so s do playlist list
widget do add action let's add the rest
this one will
be
action delete selected playlist
action
delete no no no self. action delete
selected pleas so
self do
action
delete selected playlist and you have
guess right the next one will be action
delete all playlist so action
delete all playlist and I think that
should be all for the playlist context
menu let's just copy it
the next context menu that we will
create is the
loaded
songs
context menu comment it
out and then paste it in
here well actually copy the comment
too so this one will be
called as the comment implies loaded _
songs context menu and here you know
that you have to change everything that
looks like this
to loaded song list widget but these are
not the actions will be adding here the
first one will be
action
previous duplicate it
twice action
nextest and then the next one will
be action stop oh what did I just
do action
stop okay for the separator we can leave
it as it is and what I'll do is to copy
this we need it down
here so replace
this after um
previous and next I think before that we
should have even
had the first two and then the separator
comes
in but we only need two here for the
play and then P I think they should ref
first to action
play
action pause on pause that is here so
that one to has been added and then this
place we can
say
action add selected to favorite please
this actions you have to type the name
exactly as I'm doing other than that you
may have to change their names
here so after adding the one that to
favorite you have to get
action add all to
favorite and
then action add selected so action
add selected to favorites this
one no no no no uh this one okay okay it
doesn't matter I wanted this one to be
down rather but it doesn't matter okay
and
then we need it one more
time so let's copy it that that place
you have has a lot of actions that is
why but I just hope that you really
understand what is going just adding the
actions and then separating them by line
so that we get them like this one is oh
I just did something that was not
supposed to do
okay what was it that I clicked folding
or
what okay I don't care so after to fate
what we need is I think we need just two
more for the playlist so
action save selected to save selected to
a
playlist and then we have
action save all to a playlist great so
this one will give us that one we are
left with one more which is the favorite
context menu so let's just copy maybe up
to this place that we don't really need
much there so
past why it usually goes in by one
indentation so this should
be
favorite songs context menu so self
Define favorite songs context menu and
you know that everything here that looks
like this has to change to
favorite list widget like that the last
one we even need it delete
it that's why we not even add any
separator add any separator we need only
three so without any separator the first
one is
action remove no action remove selected
from
favorite and then
action remove all from favorates
this one is not even
needed okay so now we have to make
connections to this our context
menu okay so we have to call them at the
top for them to work uh the top at the
top at the top at the top after global
before the database tab we can just
say uh
context
menus and in here we can say s do
playlist context
menu self do
loaded s context menu then s do
favorite context
menu okay so now when we right click we
should see all those functions popping
up so here and I right click you see
that all the things are popping up it
looks like the line is not really
showing but no problem and so yes that
is it the stops icon is not really
showing no problem uh you can easily fix
it by coming to the actions here where
is the action
stop you double click on it you change
the icon here fer
resource but in that case we have to run
our commands again that is no problem
because it wouldn't really affect
it okay make sure that I'm in this
page now we've made changes to it
so let's
save and one of the reasons that I don't
usually modify my main.py because now I
have to bring this one up remember this
one and then now run this command
again now you should fix this thing for
us this is how the stop is so that we
just make changes to it and run it
without having any problems but if you
come to the playlist side it has it
separate context menu for the favorites
it also has a SE separate context menu
so what we are left to do now is to
connect all these actions to their
respective functions also so let's come
up
here in fact when I was doing the build
it threw some error when I place it in
there directly that's why I place it in
the tricept now so there's also an
action called self.
action action
load selected
playlist but actions are not clicked
they are
triggered
trigger do
connect and then it will be the same
here so I can just paste it in to Lo the
playlist that is so easy so I can also
come here in the connections I just
say
playlist actions so I I give all the
playlist actions there so self do
action action save or to a playlist.
tricket do connect
I want to connect it
to self do add
all current songs to your playlist this
one course you've created all these
functions down there already and this
self dot
action save selected to a playlist do
triggered do connect we want to connect
this one to self do add
song add a song to playlist this one and
then there's also
self do
action
delete
delete all playlist do
triggered do connect we want to connect
this one also to s. delete all
playlist it should be somewhere
delete
all playlist yes this
one and then the last one for this one
will be self
dot action
delete delete selected playlist.
triet do connect we want to connect it
to S
do
delete playlist oh yeah this
one okay so that is all for the playlist
actions we can go ahead and do that for
the favorite
also under the favorite like
this you can say
favorite
actions then self do
action add selected to favorites do
trigger want to connect this one
to self. add song to favores sometimes
like that add song to favorites
yep and then let's duplicate it for a
number of times I think the are four of
them and this one will
be
action add we should have add all to
favor yes the trigger should
be add all or something like that all
songs to favores
yes and the next one is remove selected
favorites
action remove selected favorite
I remove only one song from the favorite
that will be self.
delete
delete delete
selected or you call it
remove
remove song from favorites this
one and then this will
be
action
remove all
favorites and that one should
be
remove all songs from
favorites let's just confirm to see that
these are the name of the methods that
is
true so what we are left to do now is to
also add the con C to
the the song list page okay so default
page uh actions something like
that and that one will be self
doaction
play do
triggered do connect want you to connect
to self
do play I think is is it play song or
play yeah Play song I think we have it
for about five times so let me just
duplicate it and then the next one You'
guess right is action pause and on pause
that will be S do
pause and un pause just like this and
then
action next so action next should be Ser
do next
song and then this is action
previous should be S
do
previous hey previous song not
BTN where are you going BTN and self
do action
stop s
do stop
s
yep so I think this is all all our
things should be working now I
guess let's just test a few of them out
but all of them should be
working so let me load a song
here and then
let me see add selected to playlist it
gives me the opportunity to add it to
playlist and then let me add Tech out
vibes also to the playlist and then we
will verify it from our DB function but
if I right click and hit play start is
playing but you can go to previous it's
working the nest it's working the
pause and pause
and then
the stop is also working if I come to
favorite side now of course I should be
playing a song for for me to see it at
to
favorite and so song list very happy
Christmas
play if I go to add selected to favorite
I should see a very happy Christmas at
the end of the list and it is there so
uh it is working let's come to the
playlist side
[Music]
so do you really want to delete this no
so let's create new let's a
new new one so this new one let's use it
for the delete selected you go delete
all you get this one and you say no and
then to
favorate feeling happy is multiple times
let me just Del
some
[Music]
okay so you know that all these things I
also working for I go to remov I get a
caution and I ccel out so our context
menu is
working what we have to do now in the
app I think there are just about two
things that we are done the
first is obviously not the first thing
we are doing but what we are left with
is to be able to view the content of a
playlist and that should be done by
double clicking so let's close it out
for now and then come down
to come down down down down on to where
the playlist items are I think it's here
yes and just before the context menu we
just want to group all things at one
side that relates to a particular thing
so we have to create a function that
will
show
play list
content and let's go
Define
showcore
playlist underscore
content
okay for this one I'm going to teach you
how to create custom wigets in uh it be
a custom wget I think so close your
custom widget in P5 again if you want to
learn all of these things you want to
know custom Wes and how to use all of
these in applications like if you want
to really learn the P well I you check
out my channel Tom codebase the link
will be in the description I have
interesting applications just like this
one for you to practice with but for now
let's do
trbe and then let's say
showing
playlist content
error
okay so the playlist the particular
playlist that you want to show the
content should be S do playlist list
wiget
here current item dot text that should
give it to us and then songs is equal to
fetch all songs from database table then
we pass in this particular playlist so
that it purchas the songs from the
database table for us we use it only
here
and let's just for now print these
things out and see what happen so
print
print and then you can say
playlist
let me duplicate
it and then
songs songs I think we may have to do
something extra here but for this one
the connection will be uh something a
bit a bit different from what we have
seen what we want to do now is that if
we double click on any song in the play
playlist widgets then we can show the
playlist content so let's come
up is playlist so let's keep it at the
very
top Ser playlist list
widget do
item double
clicked so if an item is double clicked
we want to
connect it to
self.
show playlist
content like that and so let's see what
we will get in our
terminal so you see that
the we get yes you get a test the
playlist and then the songs okay that's
great so we know that these are the
songs in our particular playlist
now let's go back to
development instead of pointing it to
the what did we just click instead of
printing it to the terminal what we'll
be doing is that a little popup will
show another window will pop up and then
we will display all these songs inside
like we we saw in the demo so we will
create one more file and this will be
our
last
you call
it playlist under SC
popup I will add it later Pon and so now
we have it like this what we want to do
here is
from P qt5 we want to import sorry we
want to import QT widget and then we
want to import QT GUI we also want to
import QT core and that is all we need
to
import and then a class of we can call
it
playlist
dialogue that is I think it's a best
name so QT
widget. kill
dialogue this is inheriting from that
class soore in
it and call make the super call here
too and here we have to pass in
parents
okay so for this place we will take
after s we taking other things
also and it will be the data that will
be showed inside this particular popup
we also have the list name you can
rename this to any proper term this will
just be the title that of the window
that will show so you want to make the
title Dynamic so if I double click on
test it should see songs in test if I
double click on another playlist say CS
should say songs in CS that is the list
name that I'm giving so you can actually
make a title if you think it's best or
you want make a title yeah title and
then see this parents have passed here
so I can I have to say now that parents
equal to N is a stand alone thing that
is popping
up okay and then self. data equal to
data self do title should be equal to
title it's no minus is equal to title
and then what we need to do
self do set window not outside of this
so do
set window
title that will be an F
string and then we say here that songs
in sorry
in and then
then um solve do title I think I'm
beginning to like my list name but it's
okay we have already used this one and
then self do set
geometry 550 is where we want it to be
and then
200 and then
400 300 if you look at it here you see
that a x a y a a w ah so the first one
is the X Y we start from on the screen
500 in the X Direction by pixels also
and then for the Y is be 200 down and
then the width 400 the height 300 let me
make the weight Al 500 in
Cas and then
self do set we want to set the minimum
size also so set minimum size which is
QT
core
dot k
size and we want to set it to 500 by
this
one we don't want it to be resizable
that is just what we are doing so we
setting minimum and maximum to the same
so set if you don't want that option you
can skip this one so set maximum size
also to this so that it is not
resizable then then we create a list Wes
inside this our small popup so we can
say s dot
playlist with this has nothing to do
with the one we have been working with
it is one that we are creating it is
only for this application or for this
purup so that would be QT
widget dot kill
list widgets
okay and then we passing self
here we want it to fill the whole window
that we show so we have to now give it a
layout and then make the layouts do the
responsive style fill everything inside
that is what you want to do and so what
we have to do here is say
layout so that q t
widget do QV box
layout that one to goes into self and
then we can say
layout without layout how will you add
even the items now layout. add with s do
playlist widget after that you have to
add this layout uh let me
see okay now we can see self do playlist
widget. add items this time around we
adding all the items so that will be the
data that we are passing in and yes I
just hope that this is not confusing
because it's isn't confusing at all I
think this should
do the trick so we only have to pass in
the data and then the title let us use
it in application here and
see so instead of
printing
what we want to do
is we create an instance of this
playlist dialogue so
playlist uncore
dialogue should be equal
to
playlist pop app I think that is the
name let me try and
import come on P Pam
okay you call it play dialog I think
yeah there a f name that is
playlist dialog popup but this one is
playlist dialogue so be sure to import
it where is it coming from yep and here
we have to pass in the data and then the
title so the data is
songs and then the title is the name of
the playlist so let's just give it on F
string and then can say
playlist okay and for it to show we have
to say playlist
dialogue
dotac with the
underscore and this should do all the
trick so we come here double click it
I'm sorry it came to the second screen
let me bring it is that we have it here
isn't this amazing this is working but
obviously not how we expected it to be
so let us now show only the file name in
of the the long file PA so we can just
come here and
say
songs say only equal
to OS in a list comprehension so os.
path do base name
song for song in not on in
songs okay so here instead of passing
song you have to pass songs songs only
and that should do the
trick what doing at the second screen
all the time so you see that it's
here okay so let us go ahead and
customize it a little bit
customize our playlist popup a little
bit let us
customize the
popup the first thing I want to do is to
hide all the scroll bars so in case the
the content is many hide all the scroll
bars scroll bars
okay I'll be doing some copying and
pasting here come to
music
and okay just use contr f to find scroll
bar policy this is what I'm looking for
so if you just set for scroll bar you
get something that like say set vertical
scroll bar policy set horizontal scroll
bar policy and then let's copy this
one and then come to playlist popup
paste it and then this one will not be
Ser the loaded song list which is this
one will be self. playlist with it
course my my songs are not many but if
there are many now this want to hide all
the scroll bars and make it nicer and
then we can also customize the font you
see that the font was actually very
small so we
can
customize the
font we can say that the font object
equal to K font no K
T do kill
font
okay and here we can say font do set
point size that's how we set the font
size let me give it to
14 and then uh font I also want to make
it both so font do set
bold to be true I also want to set the
weight so Set uh font sorry do set
weight
270 you can play around with these
numbers and then after that I have to do
self dot playlist widget do set font to
the font that we have just created
okay now as you see some changes in font
if I should run it
again
and this one is coming to the second
screen again you see that now is quite
big and that is I think for me this is
cool if you think otherwise you can can
change the numbers
okay and the next thing we have to do is
to
change
window
colors so that have to what we have to
do is to say self do set Styles sheet
this where we type our CSS so we can
say
background color just like CSS and then
we just say
rgba I already have this value here so
I'll type it in it is 10 for
red 25
for uh green and then 47 for blue but we
don't actually need the alpha so we can
take it off like that and then you run
it she see some
changes you can see here that it changed
the background actually changed and that
is what we want but it is making our
test almost
invisible so let's work on that one so
let's change sty sheet for the playlist
widget
also so solve. playlist widget. set
Styles sheet
and this
one you can just copy it from the music.
py the Styles sheet that is already
there for the song list wiget I think we
can just make use of it I need
everything from so just look out for
the for the find search for the S loaded
song list wiget and then look at the
Styles sheet copy it as I'm doing you
can come back to playlist pop up and
then paste it in you may not even need
all of it of course we need a color this
end it's not necessary we need a
selection background color the padding
should be okay I think I I think we need
it that that should do let's see if it
really makes it
nicer excuse
me and of course it did make it nice and
we can now see the content here
beautifully inside our popup so that is
what I was trying to see now we are left
with only one thing to do as far as I
remember if there's anything that's left
you inspect it and then add it but for
now we know that we can load it and then
it will come I didn't import any song
but here I can play
it and it is playing so what we are left
to do now is that the background should
change on every song so let's us go
ahead and then write that function real
quick back to our
main.py oh already
730 over 730 lines of
code okay so we here we can now
see
slideshow and then
Define
slideshow
okay we need one more Global variable
let's go up there and set
it we need a
global
slide index that is to keep track of the
um index of
the of we loading the image images
inside the path as a list and so we can
just like we load the song so we can use
this index to keep track of it so slide
index should be zero at
start okay if you copy or if you clone
the repository which I believe you did
then inside your you see PG images here
these are the ones that will'll be using
there's also the overlay image here okay
so this is what we'll be
calling and so back to the bottom of our
file here we can say images
_ paath is os.
path.
join what we want to join
is os. getcwd
and then another os. join because the
os. get CWD will only get me the current
working directory here but now I have to
go into
yours and I have to go into after inside
details I have to go into BG images so I
will have to join those two path also so
that together there will be one so I can
here say who.
paath do
join okay right Mr intelligence and then
here I want to join the test U
tails and
also
bore
images that's the name oh no no it's
bore I am I IM GS I
am
GS okay so this will give us the image
path and after this we can just say
images equal
to os.
path do list it's not OS do it's OS do
just OS do list there that will give us
all the items in the so we can just say
images
pass and
then you let's print this one out so you
see what is happening so print
images okay so for now I
will let's see what can I connect it
to okay let me just modify the play song
so s do SL I I'll change it back I just
want you to know I'm just looking for
one of them to give this thing
to bring up our
terminal and when I
click let me change it
back okay when I click you see that the
names you all come here but this BG
overlay is not one of them that you want
to use it's always there constant it's
this one that will be changing so you
see that it gives not the four part it
just gives the base names so the file
names themselves so we have to now uh
merge it to the path that we have
created up there for this one so what we
want to do is not to print it we want to
images do
remove and then we want to remove let's
just copy the names that we just will be
exact
yes we remove this one from it and
then call in our Global slide
index okay so if the slide
index is equal
to uh okay this that we I'm doing now
let me do it later so that you have to
you understand it well next slide
as the next next image is
images uh then we want to index it using
the slide index where is
it let me just call it
Global didn't have to deleted it slide
underscore
index to
slide
index yep bring this one down and then
we can see that the
next
image equal to
Q
GUI don't we have this
already import it from
p5t dot want to get a k pix
map this is how we treat the images so
that we OS do now we passing the image
so os. pass
do join again we want to join the images
path with a particular image so with the
in an F
string with the next slide so the next
slide here know the next slide will give
us you to use the index the global uh
the slide index to give us one of these
files depend on where it has reached so
this is just the raw file name we need
to add the full part to it before we can
use it here so that's why we are joining
it with the images path here which leads
to the images folder where the images
are being read from into this format and
then just add a particular image name so
that to give us the full part to the
file and then after that we can say self
do background image that is the name
here background image that is what we'll
be changing background
image do set pixmap
to next
image and because we want it to be for
every song we can now see that slide
index plus sorry plus equal to
one okay we are almost there so now what
we have to do
is bind this slide index to the end of
media so when when the song ends
remember that we created one function
that checks for whether the song has
ended or not and so we have to bind this
one to it come to our connections at the
top what did we give that one you have
not gotten there yet where do we give
that one this one so after the media St
change we want to now see that
self
dot player
dot media change that mean if the media
is changed and this one will make it so
intelligent that if I am looping a
particular song then the media has not
changed it's the same media that is
playing over and over again so the
background will not change but as soon
as I go previous or Nest or Shuffle then
it will change that is Source will great
do
connect and then I can connect to sell
slideshow
so now we should be having some
beautiful slideshows when we play and so
let's run it and
see one
I let's play the favorit I don't want to
load any songs now
so I ISL this one and go next and you
see that the background image has
changed prev has changed next has
changed but if I look this
song
[Music]
you see that start playing again but the
image will not
change okay there's an
error says it's not in the list or is
that is not in the
list okay let's try another one and
see the media change and why is he
saying that why was he saying that file
is not in the
list oh
it is great that we use this so I think
the that is the previous where should
be previous previous previous previous
close out of this
previous
wow was I clicking next to previous
think
next I think it should be the part
where
this was the looped
Nest oh I see
it that is simply because we have not
declared functionality here for the
favor side so after to
this can just cut it in and see that if
s do stack widget do current index equal
to
zero then this is the default one a
leave self. stack
widget dot current index equal to two
that if you are playing from the
favorite then we just have to change a
few things here
so this will
be favorite song
list and then also fav song list oh
sorry I didn't do this earlier sorry I
didn't do this
earlier so inside the fates now
play we know that the rest works so let
me Loop it
[Music]
[Applause]
fast I'm expecting to play the same song
again but the background will still
still be the same and you can see and
even if I go again it will still be the
same because the media has not changed
but as soon as I go random get to the
end shuffled next list index out of
range how can the shuffled list index be
out of
range okay let's play it again and
see Shuffle next why are these errors
now popping up
shold n should be up
here it's actually down okay
so it says the list index is out of
range and yes it is true because this
supposed to be favorite list songlist I
am very sorry that is there
disadvantages of copying and pasting and
if this one itself should be favorite
song list and I did change this one I
didn't change this ones how and why so
play I know that the rest works so let
me just shle this one now you
see and did Shuffle and it change but if
I Loop
it and then
go
I is playing the same song
but uh the background did not change
okay so that is so so so great but
there's one thing that I forgot to do
this app
works and but there's one thing that we
just forgot to do that can cost us
especially if we package this app and
send it to someone
else what will happen now if I
intentionally click on this database and
then delete that particular
folder
here let me delete it so everything is
gone everything is gone now let me run
the
app is is unable to connect unable to
open
database so as a very good practice one
of the best things that we can do is to
create this that with code inside the
App instead of creating it manually like
I did at first so that one let me see it
will come up here it will not be a class
method it's just simple function so that
will be defined let's call it
create thebore
D
and we can see that OS do make not make
the make this and what is the name of
the directory you want to make it's just
inside that place just in that
particular directory so just say
DBS and then if we make it this way and
run it it will work for the first time
we not get error I think so it says is
still unable to open database file and
that is because even though we have
created this function it's of no use to
us so what we can do is now come to the
database stuff and then call the create
the the BD this function up here so that
be it will be created when the app first
runs so now let's run it and
see and then our app runs successfully
now we come back you see that the the
DBS has been created and the database
inside has been created if you inspect
it you see that it is only our default
favorite table that is inside and
nothing more yeah so that one also works
like we expected
let's come back and now let me run it up
again and now we can we get an error
that says that cannot create a file when
that file already exists so what we need
to do now is to just add one one
parameter here then says that exists
okay and then ISS true when you put this
thing here that means that if it exist
just skip it if it doesn't exist create
it so just run it
now and then we don't get into any error
our favorites are all gone but we know
that our things work let's create two
playlist one for Dev and one
for CS one
for I think two two two is okay so let's
come back to song list add our songs our
songs are not that many but we try and
spread them to the database we know for
sure that all these are functionalities
work so I'll just click and
play just add it to my favorites and
then add a very happy cre Mouse to to my
favorite I mean adding everything to my
[Music]
favorite and is here and everything is
now working out clearly and working out
well for me okay
so let's add them to playlist also I
want to add everything here to a
playlist so add all to playlist save all
to
playlist I'll add it to Cs and then okay
inside
CS now I see that all of them have been
added here but the de should be
empty because there's no song in there
so let's just not make it feel lonely
let's add this one that is playing to
playlist to death
[Music]
and then that one too also works for
there so we know that these ones are
working we can remove the dep
unfortunately remove all which we will
not try and the favores Also let's just
add this one make it redundant try and
remove it remove all I will not even try
that one also
so our app is now
working and as we expected it to be and
this is so so great I hope you have
learned a lot along the way I hope you
have learned a lot along the way if you
do not understand anything uh you can
leave it in this comments and this is a
this is a great Community myself or
someone can will come in and then just
address your issue for you you can also
reach out to me my Channel's link will
be in the description if you want to
reach out to me personally when you go
there you you can find a an email to
contact
me find an email to contact me let me
see you can uh come in here I think when
you go
to you click somewhere here something
should take you to an about and then you
if you want to contact me this one I'm
not signed in but if you sign in you can
reach me out bya an email address over
there and then I can look at your
specific problem for you so that will be
all for this tutorial
thank you very much for your time I hope
once again that you learned a lot and
I'll see you another time maybe here on
my Channel with another interesting
tutorial thank you very much for your
time and it's bye for now but before we
go let me just play one
song okay so I'll get it from my
favorites and I'm feeling happy of
course because it has worked and
so
[Music]
yep
I forone
[Music]
now